hello everyone welcome to the november
2021 ask me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll still reporting to you from uh
my sabbatical in boston mass where i'm
visiting harvard uh it's been fun
seeing people are known for a long time
catching up getting a little bit of
science done uh collaboratively and also
meeting some people who i hadn't already
known but i will be honest
most of my time has been spent trying
very hard to finish up this book
manuscript that i'm working on so it's
been a lot of alone time in that sense
as some of you know i did this video
series last summer on the biggest ideas
in the universe and i'm turning those
videos into a series of books three
books so i just finished up uh the
manuscript for book number one or almost
finished i shouldn't curse myself there
shouldn't jinx myself the first book is
on classical physics second one's on
quantum physics and the third one is on
miscellaneous topics largely about
complexity and emergence and things like
that classical physics of course
includes general relativity and
space-time black holes things like that
the
whole point of this book series is to do
more or less straight pedagogy which is
usually not what i do most of my books
you know i try to stake out some terrain
that people can agree with or disagree
with rather than just
telling people things that we already
know
but the gimmick here is that we're doing
it with the equations so it's intro
physics but with all the equations there
including you know einstein's equation
for general relativity so i have to
explain what tensors are
what the riemann curvature tensor is in
particular what the metric is all that
stuff uh i have to teach you calculus at
least enough to understand the equations
vectors tensors what have you and that's
challenging it's hard like i'm looking
at what i'm writing i'm like oh my
goodness are people really gonna read
this i think some people are i hope some
people are some people seem to like the
videos um
i can explain more in the book than i
can in the videos and certainly
the explanations are a lot more
carefully thought out so let's put it
that way but it's still just just kind
of crazy ambitious to imagine that uh
while reading chapter two people don't
know calculus and by chapter eight uh
they're constructing the einstein tensor
for general relativity and understanding
the energy momentum tensor and so forth
so it's an experiment we'll see how it
goes um i think there's only two
analogous books that have ever been
tried that i'm aware of uh both by the
way by previous mindscape guests roger
penrose wrote of course the road to
reality his big old magnum opus a very
very long book uh which was originally
how i thought of the biggest ideas in
the universe until we decided that
splitting into three would make it a
little bit more user-friendly
um and penrose also goes through an
enormous amount of details and equations
and so forth uh the difference is i
think you know i'm actually it's weird
the difference is i'm trying to be
mainstream you know i'm not talking
about speculative stuff at all so i'm
not talking about extra dimensions of
space or
uh
the origin of the universe or anything
like that i'm just talking about the
ideas and physics that are fairly well
established and we know and mostly
penrose talks about that also but he
does so in his his own idiosyncratic way
he's a genius mathematical physicist but
he has his own slant on things uh coming
largely from a gr point of view and so
i'm really just trying to let people in
on how most theoretical physicists think
about this stuff and the other example
is lenny suskin's theoretical minimum
books another series of books um and
lenny of course has enormous physical
insight about this stuff and and
provides clarity all over the place but
it's a more traditional kind of intro
physics kind of thing
so he's really trying to bring people up
to speed enough to be physicists whereas
my goal is not to make people into
physicists it's to make them understand
the concepts and there's a gap there
right there's a difference if you want
to be a physicist you've got to just get
the textbooks and do the problem sets
and learn not only what the equations
mean but how to manipulate them how to
solve them it's one thing to understand
what all the symbols in einstein's
equation mean it's another thing to be
able to solve einstein's equation in a
particular regime or you know do an
approximation scheme or put it on a
computer or what have you uh so suskin's
approach is more just intro physics
whereas mine is leaping ahead so i'm
doing things on black holes and quantum
field theory and so forth that he never
gets to in his books so i think it is
different um hopefully it will be uh
accessible to some people you know
explaining tensors is not easy explain
the hamiltonian formulation of classical
mechanics requires partial derivatives
which involve funny symbols i do think
that just the funniness of the symbols
is a big thing right i mean uh the
existence of greek letters when you do
tensors in space-time can be extremely
intimidating and for good reason you
know if it's an injk
then at least we've seen those letters
before where if it's mu nu and lambda
that's an extra layer of intimidation
that the symbols get you but
it shouldn't be you know from a purely
cognitive point of view they're just
symbols who cares but you know you have
to understand that when you say okay
this d in this font means ordinary
derivative and this sort of curly
looking d in a different font means
partial derivative and that has to do
with when you have more than one
variable
you have to sort of acknowledge the fact
that that is intrinsically intimidating
or
hard to instantly grasp even if the
underlying concepts are actually not
that hard
so you know i'm constantly trying to
put things into context make it easy
without going at you know tremendous
length right i mean i want to keep
everything compact enough that you can
swallow it in a reasonable amount of
time uh rather than just doing a million
different examples and things you know
doing enough examples to get the point
and then move on quickly again we'll see
i'm talking about this because this is
what is on my mind right now trying my
best to make uh the biggest ideas
understandable to everybody
anyway uh this is this month's ask me
anything episode uh as always the ask me
anything episodes are brought to you by
the uh people who are contributing to
mindscape via patreon if you would like
to be such a person you can go to
patreon.com sean m carroll and uh chuck
in a buck or two for episode that would
be wonderful the patreon um supporters
are great for many reasons they bring us
not only these ask me anything episodes
they get um
ad-free versions of the episodes that
they can listen to and they also
basically are paying for other things
like the transcripts that we get of
every episode so there's transcripts
both of the ama episodes but literally
every episode of mindscape you can get
transcripts at
preposterousuniverse.compodcast
so if you want to search how many times
has he mentioned renormalization or some
the guest has mentioned something like
that or the hard problem of
consciousness you can find all that uh
at preposterousuniverse.com podcast
we've built up you know it's been over
three years built up a big uh
backlog of people talking about
interesting things so let's add to it
and let's go
[Music]
paul hardy says when i studied
psychology i learned of a phenomenon
whereby rats were taught new tasks that
took a certain amount of time to learn
and as time went on rats in other parts
of the world learn these new tasks at a
statistically significant faster rate
i know physics would say there's no
signal that could account for this and
i've never found a good answer do you
have any wisdom on this uh yeah so the
idea is someone somewhere teaches rats
how to do it something and somewhere
where presumably
it's different rats
they started learning faster so one
hypothesis which you might write down is
that rats
share sort of collective consciousness
and the minds of rats across the world
share information about how to do tasks
that is a hypothesis
there's another hypothesis that says
that the result is just wrong that you
it was a mistake or they lied that's a
hypothesis there's a hypothesis that
says that
knowledge of the psychology experiment
was shared around and people thought
about it and they became better at
teaching the rats that's certainly a
hypothesis
there's a hypothesis that it was just
the statistical fluctuation that even
though statistically significant what
that often means especially in
psychology experiments is 95 confidence
or maybe 99 confidence and in the real
world one percent and five percent
unlikely things happen all of the time
so of these hypotheses i would say say
that the ones that violate the laws of
physics as we know them which include uh
the minds of rats sharing information
around the world is the least likely of
all of those uh it's very very very
unlikely and i understand why i picked
this question not because i have any
special um
knowledge about rats or
insight into psychology experiments or
anything like that remember that i pick
the questions to ask i can't to answer i
don't answer all of them but if i have
something that i think is interesting to
talk about vis-a-vis the question then i
will choose it so in this case it's the
fact that you know all these individual
alternative explanations seem a little
fudgy right oh there was a mistake you
know there's just a statistical
fluctuation they rub us the wrong way
but
changing the laws of physics to give
rats telepathy
should be just enormously low on your
list of plausible hypotheses for
something like this uh because we have
so much knowledge about how physics
works and but pretty good knowledge
about how rats work and none of this is
uh is very likely so even though the
alternatives
all seem a little bit you know
you're reaching a little bit it's
nowhere near the amount of reaching that
you need to do
to uh really change up the laws of
physics and the laws of rats so i don't
know what the correct explanation is but
this is a general feature of reasoning
about these weird claimed studies i mean
i don't know the studies you're talking
about i don't know if you could produce
a
reference to them and so forth i should
say there's a whole nother hypothesis
which is that
the
study or the result that you're
remembering or you're mentioning if you
were to dig into the actual study isn't
nearly as impressive sometimes these
studies uh these these crazy results get
amplified a little bit in the game of
telephone uh that constitutes people
sharing things like that i mean it would
be enormously great to discover
something like telepathy among rats or
collective communal consciousness uh and
it's it's provocative and therefore
people share it they go huh what about
this that doesn't mean you should
provide any credence to the possibility
really i'd put it at about .0001 or
something like that my personal credence
in that hypothesis
daniel janzen says as i understand
heisenberg's uncertainty principle it is
only a statement about the variance of
two complementary variables in repeated
experiments an experimental setup that
results in low variance in one variable
has high variance in the other are there
no implications at all if you measure
first say the position and momentum on
the same particle uh yeah there are
absolutely
experimental implications for measuring
the same particle and that in fact
that's where the implications are most
obvious
most dramatic if you take
literally the idea that you're measuring
the position of a particle
and you measure it very accurately then
after the measurement you know strictly
nothing about its momentum because a
position a localized quantum state sorry
let me say this way a quantum state that
is localized in position
is completely delocalized in momentum
and vice versa the states that have
small variations in position and momenta
uh simultaneously are a different kind
of state they're they they're you cannot
have a small variation in one and and um
very small variation one and also very
small variation in the other so the
heisenberg uncertainty principle is a
statement about what how quantum states
relate to observables it's actually not
a statement about measurement or
experimental results at all it is a
statement about how quantum states
relate to observables and we can make
the statement very very crisp and clear
if you think about spins instead of
position and momentum so just like
position momentum or complementary
variables
in the heisenberg uncertainty principle
so are the spin in the z direction and
the spin in the x direction okay so it's
kind of hard to
visualize sometimes or to grasp but in
hilbert space in the space of all
possible quantum states a spin in one
direction let's say spin up
is perpendicular
as a vector in hilbert space to spin in
the other direction which is spin down
and the reason why that's hard to
visualize is of course we think of a
little axis
spin up going up and spin down going
down and those are parallel to each
other up and down or parallel even
though they point opposite directions
but as states in hilbert space they're
perpendicular to each other that's why
we say that a particular spin can be in
a superposition of spin up and spin down
it's the two different possibilities
spin up or spin down okay but that's
along a particular axis and so consider
a spin
so it's vector in hilbert space is in a
little two-dimensional plane the x-axis
is
let's say the horizontal axis is the
spin up axis the vertical axis is the
spin down axis and the real vector is a
little line segment of length one
pointing from the origin to somewhere on
that plane okay so you can imagine
orienting that line segment along the
horizontal axis and then you say it's
spin up
you can imagine oriented along the
vertical axis you say it's spin down you
can imagine orienting it along somewhere
in between and then you say okay it
could be either one
and the uncertainty principle
says that if you have well it comes from
the fact that if you instead of that
spin along the let's say that was the
z-axis story that we just told
horizontal axis is spin up along the z
axis vertical axis is spin down along
the z axis then the spin x axis the x
the x spin description
is rotated at 45 degrees okay so spin up
along the
x-axis
corresponds to an axis on the in hilbert
space which is at 45 degrees it's in
between
the spin up on z-axis and spin down on
the z-axis you take the two axes you
spin up and spin down at right angles
you rotate them
by 45 degrees and now you get spin up
along the z axis
sorry along the x-axis and spin down
along the x-axis okay
so the point of all that is that going
from one complement one observable the
z-spin to the complementary observable
the x-spin is a rotation of the axes and
the same thing is true in position of
momentum although it's more complicated
it's they're infinite dimensional
and the uncertainty principle is just
the statement that
if i just consider
the z-spin i can orient my quantum state
so that it's entirely along spin up or
spin down or it's halfway in between
likewise i can do the same for the x
spin i can orient it so it's entirely
along spin up x or spin down x but
because those two sets of axes are
rotated at 45 degrees with respect to
each other there's no way that i can
have a quantum state that is perfectly
aligned with spin up in the z direction
and spin down in the x direction
in fact there's no way i can align it so
that it's a has a perfect variable
perfect prediction
that is
both true for x and z anyway in any
possible direction because the two axes
are rotated with respect to each other
that's the heisenberg uncertainty
principle the uncertainty principle is
just saying
you can't simultaneously localize a
quantum state along two complementary
observable axes because they're rotated
with respect to each other
and notice that i didn't make any
statements there about observables or
measurements or experiments or anything
like that observables i did sorry
measurements for experiments i did not
talk about
so eric chen says i'm going to group two
talk two
topics together two questions together
eric chenton says what are your thoughts
on long-termism the view that positively
influencing the long-term future is
among the key moral priorities of our
time relatedly what is your take on the
effective altruism movement which many
people who endorse long-termism are a
part of and henry coxley asks the
basically the same question what are the
best arguments for and against
strong long-termism i'm not quite sure
what the word strong is doing there i'm
not an expert on long-termism but um
uh it's one of its pioneers was nick
bostrom who we had on on the podcast a
while back
we did of course the idiosyncratic thing
about mostly talking about the anthropic
principle rather than talking about
existential risk or super intelligence
or anything like that but it was a fun
conversation
and you know
these
perspectives of effective altruism and
long-termism come out of a particular
kind of
consequentialist moral outlook okay
um
and a version of trying to be rational
in the face of a consequentialist moral
outlook where you're trying to maximize
something
you know all the good experiences that
people have throughout history let's
maximize that right it's a sensible
thing to imagine trying to do now as as
you know as i said before i'm not really
a utilitarian um i go back and forth i'm
not really a non-utilitarian either and
i've said it before and i'll keep saying
it my i don't yet
i have not settled on
a once and for all favorite way of
thinking about uh
consequentialism versus deontology
versus virtue ethics etc i do have a
podcast coming up uh with someone who is
utilitarian and is in favor of effective
altruism and made some very very good
points so look forward to that soon
um
but i'm not myself i have i have worries
about it
on the other hand you know there's i
guess what
maybe are is weak long-termism or weak
effective altruism which is obviously
perfectly sensible to me
given that i would like to be an
altruist i would like my altruism to be
effective that sounds pretty good i'd
rather be effective than ineffective
altruism
likewise i think the long term matters
you know i'm not in favor of uh taking
wild risks that could end the existence
of life on earth within 100 years that
sounds bad to me i think that people who
exist in future generations should also
count so that's you know kind of obvious
and simple um
but
i also think that
there's a mistake that we can make by
and this is a mistake many utilitarians
make in my view they would say that it's
not a mistake obviously but it's to
count the lives and experiences of
people elsewhere and at other times
equally
to how we count our experiences of
myself living now other people near to
me and people i know etc
it seems parochial and selfish to say
that i should count people near to me in
my moral calculus more than people far
away from me why does the life of
someone who i happen to be looking at
right now count more than the life of
someone across the globe right
but i think there are paradoxes that
come up if you don't take that point of
view um
in economics for example we always
discount the future
we count
individual
considerations for people for
individuals in the future less than for
the present day in part just because we
can't predict them very well right um
our effects are harder to know when
they're applied to far away lands and
far away times
so it's perfectly rational to discount
in some sense and in fact i think i
don't know if anyone has ever made
specifically this argument but
there are versions of arguments against
utilitarianism
which try to point out how
uh counter rational it is to really be a
perfect utilitarian and i think that
what it comes down to is the
impossibility of finding a well-defined
measure on infinitely big sets right if
we count potentially an infinite number
of people
i mean and we count all them equally
then literally the only moral thing to
do right now is to try to prevent the
heat death of the universe
and i don't think that's true i don't
think that should follow from any
reasonable moral starting point um
so i so i think that it it probably
compared to what we actually do in terms
of being good human beings uh
governments and corporations and
influential organizations trying to
affect the future of the world i think
we should probably be more long-term
than we are right i think that people
don't put a lot of effort into thinking
about the future um and
i think that the sort of
bare thing of preserving the human race
you know stopping us from going extinct
that should be a very high priority
um but beyond that i think that so
compared to what we actually do i it
would be in favor of more long-termism
on the other hand i don't want to take
this extreme view that just pretends
that everyone counts equally every time
counts equally and we should
adopt our present strategies with that
in mind i don't think that quite fits
together in part because of this
uncertainty like i said
you know and in part because of this
fundamental flaw in
uh utilitarianism so i mean but put it
this way
consider two possible futures for the
human race in one future um we figure
out
the work week and
leisure time and basic income for
everyone and we have a thousand years
maybe 10 000 years if you really want to
push it but you know we have some number
of millennia where everyone is happy
and everyone is healthy you know given
the contingencies of life and
unpredictabilities etc but everyone
basically lives a good life they can
pursue their passions they you know
they're free from constraints of
scarcity and hunger and all that stuff
they get good educations they learn to
live together but it only lasts a
thousand or a few thousand years
the other one is
we last for i don't know um a
quadrillion years a thousand trillion
years right with trillions and trillions
and trillions of human beings but they
all live in squalor and misery right and
you can pump up the numbers to be
whatever you want given utilitarianism
given the fact that we're just
maximizing something utility or number
of happy moments or whatever it is you
can always find
a large enough number of miserable
people that you get more utility out of
that than a small number of happy people
that's the fundamental problem with
utilitarianism you can always win just
by adding more people to the game uh and
i think that's wrong and i'm it's not
like super obviously wrong don't get me
wrong um
but but i think that a short-term future
where people truly flourish i would say
is actually preferable to a long-term
future where people are basically
miserable and i think that uh the the
straightforward naive long-termist
calculus would disagree with me on that
so i haven't you know
i dabbled on about it just now but i
haven't really put a lot of thought into
this i think it's important to be
talking about these things i think the
the overall lesson is that
uh there's a certain amount of epistemic
humility that is required when you're
calculating things of the form x times y
where x is a number much much larger
than one and y is a number much much
less than one
so when you take a very big number and
multiply it by a tiny fraction this is
always the game that is being played by
these very long term calculations you
know well if there's a 0.001 chance that
humanity will go extinct but there's
huge damage if humanity goes extinct
right that's the kind of calculation
that is done and you say well you know
we should forget about climate change
and and poverty and disease and war and
try to go from .001 chance that humanity
will go extinct 2.001 chance
um i hope i said that correctly but
i don't buy that i do not agree with
that kind of reasoning because i think
that there are generally error bars on
those numbers that you're talking about
that kind of wash out all the effect um
same thing is true for everybody in
quantum mechanics when you're talking
about these ridiculously unlikely
branches of the wave function right
people really focus on these because
they don't like the implications
but don't focus on these really unlikely
things in in these calculations i think
that
our uncertainties about those should be
very large and they should not drive our
fundamental decision-making processes
that would be my short
version of my
unconsidered take
lenio miziara says david albert said
that when an amoeba splits it doesn't
really make sense to choose one of the
descendants as the real one you've said
that in many worlds and we split the
destiny of our copies doesn't really
matter to us
because they will go on to live happily
entirely independent lives from ours he
didn't say happily sorry just entirely
independent lives
however doesn't that imply that we are
choosing one of the copies as the real
myself isn't that just like choosing one
of the descendants of the amoeba um no
it's not all like that the point is that
there are many future copies of me
each one of them should look out for
their own interests likewise if you take
some past version of me i am one of the
descendants of that past version i shall
look out for my own interest there's
nothing i can do that affects what's
happening to the other copies of my from
my other descendants of my past self
that doesn't mean i'm special to them
they're special you know just as much as
i am special no there's no godlike view
that is pointing out any one of the
copies as uh more important than any of
the other ones
mark clark says is there any physics
prediction for what existed before the
big bang
uh i wouldn't say prediction i mean
literally can't be a prediction for what
existed before the big bang it's in the
past um
but there's scenarios right i mean the
amount of knowledge we have or even
confidence high credence scenarios is
very very small i wouldn't put too much
weight on any of the scenarios that we
have but it's possible that nothing
existed before the big bang by which i
don't mean there was something that
existed before the big bang called
nothing what i mean is there might be no
such thing as before the big bang right
and that's probably what is the
traditional view of the big bang that it
is the beginning of time it's also
completely possible there was a
contracting universe that bounced it's
also completely possible there was a
more or less quiescent universe that
somehow bubbled off a universe like ours
there's many different possibilities to
it you know i do think let me just take
this opportunity to say
i think that not enough
[Music]
brain power is put on considering the
possibility that the big bang was not
the beginning and it wasn't them a
special event either
a lot of scenarios that try to invent a
picture for what space time could have
been doing before the big bang
make it either like the mirror image of
our universe you know some contracting
universe or something like that but it
could have been a completely different
kind of thing it could have been like i
said just quiescent empty space time
which is the scenario that i put forward
with jennifer chen or it could have been
something just very radically different
you know even the people who'd like to
think about time before the big bang
still want to attach some specialness to
the big bang that's a sort of natural
move to make and i think it's not
necessarily
uh the only move we should be thinking
about
all right i'm gonna group two questions
together let's see if i can remember why
i grouped them
joseph williams says
do you ever think that's too much
information to be a coincidence for me
the fact that the chemical makeup of
stars and their distance is communicated
by a light across the universe seems
more than just happenstance seems
there's too much information suggesting
something more fundamental and profound
is at play
gary upshaw says ancient astronomers and
philosophers and european astronomers
were inspired by patterns of movement of
the sun moon and planets across the
heavens
from these patterns they learn to
predict eclipses eventually to discover
law of gravity the orbits of the moon
and planets is fairly simple in a single
sun system if the system was a tucson
system do you think humans would have
advanced scientifically
right now i'm remembering why i'm
grouping these two things together uh so
both questions are about
so i would classify these as saying look
here's our universe here's the universe
that we know and love look at all the
amazing stuff we've done
and if we lived in a different kind of
universe then we wouldn't have been able
to do that amazing stuff in exactly the
same way right so joseph is saying we
get spectral information from stars that
lets us analyze their chemical
composition gary is saying that the
motions of the planets in a single sun
dominated system is fairly simple that
helped us work out kepler's laws and
newton's laws and eclipse timings and
things like that so i would say this is
extraordinarily exposed facto reasoning
it is of the same character as
the famous uh
claims about how you know the the
it's purported well it's supposed to be
a reductio ab insertum like looking at a
puddle right and you say wow look at
that the shape of the water in the
puddle is exactly the same to fit
exactly what is necessary to fit right
into the shape that is created by the
mud that the puddle uh that formed the
puddle in the first place isn't that a
remarkable coincidence and of course the
answer is it's not remarkable at all the
shape of the indentation of the ground
comes first and then the water settles
into that shape right it's supposed to
be response to fine-tuning arguments
likewise i would say that you know
whenever uh
anyone says that isn't it remarkable how
much progress we're able to make from
scientific data uh whether it's the the
spectra of stars or the orbits of the
planets and the sun and by the way robin
collins who's a theologian has tried to
systematize this he actually claims that
the laws of physics are maximized for
discoverability right they make it easy
as possible easy as conceivable to
discover things about the universe but
that's just because what that's happened
to us
that's because that's the particular way
that we were able to make progress
there's lots of things we can't make
progress on we don't know what the dark
matter is we don't know what happened at
the big bang right i mean 200 years ago
would be easy to come up with a list of
things we didn't know it took us a while
to invent quantum mechanics and so forth
the idea that somehow
scientific progress or knowledge of the
universe has been made easy by features
of the universe it seems entirely off
base to me there's a selection effect
you know we're impressed by the stuff
that we can discover first if the laws
of physics or the situation the universe
were very different there's other stuff
we would discover first and we would
call that amazing right
um there's no in other words a priori
expectation for how easy it should be to
discover things about the universe with
respect to which we can compare our
actual experience
there is something about the universe to
be fair to the other side
the universe is largely intelligible
right it obeys rules it obeys patterns
there are discernible patterns the laws
of physics that we can discover
um
is that surprising or not i really have
no way of judging but i get the question
you know in the in the space of all
possible laws of physics
i can imagine that the vast vast
majority of them would be very very hard
to discern
so in some sense like you know we have
locality for example the most obvious
thing in the world determinism is
another pretty obvious thing uh but the
fact that we live in a world governed by
field theory and the fields only
interact with each other when they're
the same point in space time okay that's
a huge huge restriction on all the
possible things i could easily imagine
laws of physics that would let rats
communicate
telepathically the best ways to run
through mazes and things like that but
we don't have those laws of physics
so that is a fact about the universe
that is certainly non-generic
in the space of all possible laws of
physics uh is it
surprising that i have let much less to
say about um
there could if we're super duper
ambitious and i'm actually thinking
about this there could be a selection
effect a dynamical selection effect
that uses emergence to say that when
there are
creatures
intelligent creatures that can look at
the world and think about it like us
that emerge given laws of physics they
will always discern more or less
intelligible laws of physics so there
could again be some kind of anthropic
selection
that in the parts of the multiverse if
it's something like that where there
exist human beings they can or other
intelligent beings they will see simple
patterns in the laws of physics but you
know that's a very very speculative
crazy idea it's not something that we
can say oh yes it must be like that
martin ducheck says
when science fiction talks about using
black holes as a slingshot mechanism
where does this energy come from if it
comes from rotational energy does this
mean it wouldn't work with non-spinning
black holes um well i don't know what
scientific what science fiction stories
you're talking about so maybe they're
just making stuff up that's that's
always possible
um maybe a better way to ask it is is it
conceivable to use black holes as
slingshots in ways that are compatible
with energy conservation and other
cherished laws of physics and i think
the answer is yes and there's at least
two different ways i mean one way is
just to use black holes in a similar way
that we use planets in the real world
right
nasa and other space agencies when they
are launching probes around the solar
system will very often use what is
called the gravitational assist from
other planets so you have jupiter out
there and you can slingshot around
jupiter and use that as a way to
go a lot faster and you should ask
yourself well where did the energy come
from to make your spaceship move a lot
faster and the answer is jupiter is
orbiting the sun
it has some velocity it has some
momentum and has some angular momentum
and jupiter slows down by a tiny tiny
tiny amount completely imperceptible
but it gives a little bit of its energy
and its angular momentum to your
spacecraft
so there's nothing violating anything
about that and likewise if you have
black holes that are moving
in some reference frame that you care
about
you can borrow a little of their
momentum to slingshot a spacecraft or
something like that but that could also
be done with planets or stars you don't
need a black hole to do that
there is something special about black
holes called the penrose process named
after former mindscape guest roger
penrose have i mentioned that that he
was on minescape
so one of the things that penrose
invented the 1960s is something called
the penrose process if you have a
rotating black hole you can again
in a similar you know spiritually uh
equivalent vein to borrowing
uh rotational energy from jupiter you
can borrow rotational energy from a
spinning black hole uh the specific way
you do it is a little bit trickier but
roughly speaking you fly near the black
hole you throw something into the black
hole in the direction opposite its
rotation so you slow it down
and in response you are kicked out
faster than you went in
and the black hole slows down a little
bit and the fun thing about this is that
there's a limit on it because you're
throwing things into the black hole
slowing down its rotation and therefore
making it a more more slowly rotating
black hole and in the process you can
prove stephen hawking famously this is i
think one of his first big theorems the
area theorem the area of the event
horizon of the black hole always goes up
you can extract energy from the black
hole if it's spinning but the area of
its event horizon will always increase
along the way so maybe that's what your
science fiction stories are talking
about i'm not really sure
okay now i have a bunch of questions
that are kind of groupable
about uh they're all about personal
identity in some sense um
so but i'm gonna read them separately
and try to answer them separately uh
but anyway there's a theme for the next
couple questions so lars krueger says do
you think that the continuity of
personal identity consciousness is an
illusion and how would you argue that
it's not
um so no i don't think it's an illusion
but i think that the answer involves
mostly a careful
thinking about what we mean by illusions
not a careful thinking about what we
mean by consciousness i don't think
there's anything special about
consciousness i think the continuity of
personal
sorry not a personal identity but
there's a continuity of identity of the
chair i'm sitting on right there's a
very real sense in which the chair i'm
sitting on is the same chair i sat on
yesterday
what is that sense what does that mean i
mean it's a set of collection of atoms
etc but it's at a different moment of
time i could be like really hardcore
about saying that the chair at one
moment is a different chair than another
moment a different thing it's a
collection of atoms at a different
moment of time it's had a different
location in space time right
but it's dumb to be that hardcore you
could be it's you know it's consistent
but you are uh letting go of an
enormously useful handle that you have
on the world namely the knowledge that
comes in a very compact usable form by
saying
the chair that was there yesterday
it implies a whole bunch of things i
remember what it was like to sit on the
chair yesterday that's probably going to
be pretty similar to what it's like to
sit on the chair today
if the chair has you know a wheel that
is about to fall off it's probably still
true today
if i need to put a pillow on it to make
it comfortable likewise so
what we do in the real world
is to group things together in ways that
provide us a handle on the real world
that is useful right we don't want to
separately
pretend to specify the position and
velocity of every particle in the
universe at every separate moment of
time that's a silly way of thinking
about the universe we can't do it so
instead we group things together that's
what emergence is all about coarse
graining is all about you chunk things
together uh into
groups
that qualify as entities that are
describing
rough approximations of the specific
underlying particular
configuration of fundamental stuff okay
and that's where the continuity comes
from the fact that if someone says you
know i sat on the chair yesterday it was
comfortable that makes predictions for
the future right it gives us a handle on
the world it predicts it'll probably
still be comfortable today
um and i think exactly the same thing is
true for the continuity of personal
identity right i mean it's useful not
because it's some fundamental
category in the universe but it helps us
understand and talk about
the universe in useful ways if you are
talking about a certain person that you
know a friend of yours and you say well
you know they're they're always very
persnickety about what they eat okay
that provides you some useful
information
about how to feed them and how to treat
with them uh if they come over to your
house or something like that so that's
the sense in which uh personal identity
is not an illusion it's it's real it can
it's continuous over time in that sense
and i can make it first person if you
want you know when i say that i ate too
much yesterday and that's predicting and
explaining certain features of my uh my
feeling today right that's exactly what
is going on i don't think it's anything
spooky anything fundamental it's a
higher level emergent reality but that's
very very different than being an
illusion an illusion is something where
you think x is true but x is false
right and a higher level of merchant
thing is very useful and true an
illusion is when the magician pulls a
rabbit out of a hat and it makes you
think that there was no rabbit there and
he made a rabbit appear that's an
illusion
but the continuity of personal identity
over time is not an illusion that's a
very real thing
all right matisse raymakers says a
priority question remember priority
questions are the ones where you can ask
them and i will do my best to answer
them i won't answer everyone's questions
but
every for every person who is a patreon
supporter once in their life gets to ask
a priority question and then i will try
my best to answer that priority question
now the problem is you know if you don't
like my answer you don't get a do-over
so this is it's an ama this is not a
truth service or uh i promise to give
you satisfaction service this is you can
ask me a question i will give you an
answer and then you have to deal with
the answer so with that in mind
matisse's question is
uh the thought experiment here below is
giving me a headache and seems to imply
that assuming functionalism infinity of
space and finite dimensionality of the
hilbert space of a human brain any first
order perspective is in a sense
non-local
please have a shot of debunking it i'm
building two identical conscious robots
that run a deterministic programs and i
run i place them into identical rooms
room one and room two both with a single
door on the outside of each door there's
a plate with a room number now i turn on
the robot in room 1 tell him he's in
room 1 and let him explore without
opening the door after some time i turn
the robot off copy its memory banks
perfectly to the robot in room 2 with
the memory stick update the position etc
turn the room 2 robot on from the
robot's perspective nothing interesting
happened and he would only be surprised
to find himself in room two after
opening the door
you might argue this robot only thinks
he's the same robot in room one but his
feeling of self
meets the same standards as those of you
calling yourself of several days you at
least this is what functionalism assumes
now i repeat the experiment it's a long
question sorry folks
but instead of only switching on the
robot in room two i switch on both
robots simultaneously and i tell them
the trick that i pulled now both robots
will be unable to tell me with certainty
in which room they are does this mean
that from their perspective they are
either the robot in room one or room two
and they just don't know
or
they're in a sort of limbo of which
robot they are
while the first option seems intuitive
it implies that somehow during the
copying a choice was made but the data
on the memory stick is always the same
as in the first experiment if the choice
was made when the robots were turned on
why not 10 seconds after they were
turned on the alternative seems to be a
sort of limbo until they open the door
which itself sounds ridiculous so i
think there are two things um two points
i will make i'm not sure if i will offer
a satisfactory complete answer to the
question but two points i can make with
some degree of confidence
one is that
all of these kinds of duplicating
transporting teleporting
experiments um give us philosophical
trouble because they never happen in the
real world right we have no experience
being duplicated and held in a room
so
all of the ways we have of talking about
personal identity as we were just
talking about
all of the reasons for which it is
useful
to talk about who we are in the world
etc and attach some identity continuity
over time
um are predicated on our actual
experience of the world in which these
duplication experiments never happen
so it shouldn't be surprising is the
first point i want to make that when you
violate the uh things that actually
we're familiar with in the real world
you come across situations which don't
fit comfortably with our categories okay
just so we don't have a right to demand
that the categories we invent for
certain circumstances always make
perfect sense and fit perfectly
comfortably with new circumstances that
we're considering that's point number
one point number two is that
there is something about this experiment
room one and room two that exist not
only in the minds of the robots but in
the minds of the outside world
we're allowed to if we're considering
what is true and good about the world
think about the whole system and its
relationship to other things so the
short answer i think is that there is
absolutely a fact of the matter
about which room the robots are in
there's a robot in room one a robot in
room two there's i think there's zero
ambiguity about that now
you can put into the robot in room two
all of the memories and impressions of
the robot in room one sure and then they
wrote i would just say the robot in room
two is just wrong right you fooled them
good for you you fooled the robot in
room two um i don't think this has any
deep implications for human
consciousness or anything like that at
all because we don't
uh or you know
human identity or anything like that
because again these things don't happen
to us you know in other words i think
that it is perfectly okay
to develop theories of human
consciousness and identity that only try
to apply
to the kinds of circumstances we've
already
experienced in the world and the fact
that they can be inconsistent and
experience in circumstances we've never
experienced doesn't bother me that much
what i would say is if you have new
circumstances outside our realm of
experience then you can invent new rules
right i mean you can assign new little
subscripts to the identities of the
robots you can call both of them you
know robot sub 1 robot sub 2 or you know
whatever they are
you can include the perspectives of
people outside i i don't have a once and
for all solution to what you should do
but i'm just saying that there's no
reason to think that our
understanding that is developed in the
real world has an unambiguous resolution
in cases like this that's what i would
say
okay flying waffle also asks a priority
question
regarding the hard problem of
consciousness one basic observation is
that as conscious beings we seem willing
and able to talk about our subjective
experiences with one another even if
imperfectly for example we all
understand what is meant by the question
why am i mean or why am i experiencing
the particular life of sean carroll
rather than the life of sir isaac newton
of course the words i am and me are all
very ambiguous and can't be really
separated from one another but as a
series of symbols mapped onto neurons
this sentence is nothing special
on the flip side if we ever build
intelligent machines and they're not
conscious like we are it seems hard to
imagine how they could ever come up with
that question spontaneously on their own
but what's truly curious about the
concept of identity implied by the
question why am i mean is that if you
and i were to swap places neither one of
us would even notice there's been a swap
could all could this all indicate that
consciousness is strongly linked the
formation and recollection of memories
rather than to cognition and
intelligence
so i'm going to deny a lot of the
implications for a lot of the
assumptions you're making here um
you know i think that
it is
questions like why am i me or rather
than am i not sir isaac newton these are
paradigmatic cases i would say of ways
that we can make
sentences that are grammatically correct
and seem on the surface to
apply to not our world but at least
conceivable possible worlds but really
they don't they just dissolve under
further investigations i think that the
question why am i me rather than why am
i surprising newton makes no sense
whatsoever not even a little bit of
sense
i can imagine what it would be like if a
person like me
were somehow transported into the body
of sir isaac newton but basically with
my own memories intact that would be
weird and and strange and i would have
trouble dealing with life
um but it would be completely different
than sir isaac newton himself
uh and i think this is
exactly the problem you come across when
you try to ask these kinds of questions
why am i me there's no other person you
could be right i mean that's that's by
definition it really is that trivial i
think
um
you can again talk about you know slight
variations on yourself to give yourself
some of the features that other people
have and wonder what you would do in
those circumstances
um but it's a similar problem with
things like reincarnation like if i say
oh i'm the reincarnation of cleopatra i
don't know and i say but i have no
memories of being cleopatra those were
wiped clean in the in the reincarnation
process that what does that mean that
means nothing whatsoever and likewise i
think that there's no meaning to the
idea like if i were isaac newton right
isaac newton is a different person than
me so i just think you should unask
these kinds of questions
uh
also i think that i have zero trouble
seeing imagining that intelligent
machines could say you know why do i
have these experiences rather than
others like i
i think that we train our feelings about
how machine acts machines act uh using
the machines we have like the laptop
right in front of me right now but
that's gonna be very far from what
machines are ultimately able to do so i
see i have no
problem thinking that intelligent
machines could ask all these existential
questions both the well-formed ones and
the not well-formed ones there you go in
other words i have no trouble imagining
that artificial intelligence could make
the same kind of mistakes
philosophically that we human beings
make
okay that was the group of questions i
wanted to put together you see why
they're grouped together even though uh
i answered them separately
jaya fall says what are your feelings
about censorship on social media
so this is a tricky one this is a
complicated question the very very short
answer is that i'm all for it
censorship on social media
but that's only because of course
everyone is for censorship on social
media in the broadest possible sense you
know no one ever thought uh if you if
you define censorship on social media as
a company running a social media
platform allowing certain kinds of
speech or acts on their medium and not
others right
um
before the existence of the internet and
computers and so forth we thought we had
something called free speech freedom of
expression but nobody thought that every
individual had the right to march up to
the newspaper in their town and demand
that they print their screed right
you didn't have a right to access to the
printing press that is owned by somebody
else um and likewise on social media um
even the you know there's always these
new ones popping up that claim to be the
real free speech uh platform etc and
then there's a long list of restrictions
but you can't have pornography you can't
threaten to kill someone or commit
crimes or whatever right there are
always these restrictions
so the question is not should there be
censorship on social media that's the
dumb easy question the hard question is
uh you know how far should it go and who
should be in charge of doing it right
and these are hard questions and these
are legitimately hard and i don't have
super duper well thought out answers to
them um other than i would resist a
little bit
finding overly simplistic answers um
you know my
tendency my initial inclination is to be
in favor of speech of all sorts let it
go out there i was you know i i was not
in favor of kicking donald trump off of
twitter for example um although you know
if you're a consequentialist i think
that the consequences of that have been
very good so maybe i was wrong about
that again i don't have very strong uh
feelings about it
um but you can't be completely
absolutist about it it just doesn't work
for all sorts of reasons and i think
it's very known that it doesn't work you
know go back and listen to the
conversation i had with teresa beijan
who's really thought she has unlike me
thought professionally about uh these
issues and she says that you know she
started out as more or less a free
speech absolutist but it just doesn't
work for a whole bunch of reasons and
this is a little bit off topic but you
know it's it's related to
a bunch of conversations that are going
on on social media of all places
um about free speech and and uh
censorship and letting people
uh give talks and hold their jobs and
you know criticizing people and
canceling them and punishing them for
previous speech etc and so the one thing
i will say even though these are
complicated issues and i don't want to
oversimplify them
um
the one thing i will say is
again as as someone who's mostly on the
pro free speech side
my my fellow pros free speech people
make really a whole bunch of
embarrassingly bad arguments i have to
say and it you know it it disconcerts me
a little bit and here's the
the way in which they make
embarrassingly bad arguments they make
it entirely procedural
they completely ignore the substance of
what is going on and as i just said that
never works right even the most
pre-speech platforms will always have
footnotes about what kinds of speech are
not allowed you can't shout fire in a
crowded theater we all know that we all
know that there are restrictions on
speech that are substantively based
so the ques the hard question is where
you draw those lines and that's an
interesting and important question we
should address it but what happens is
people don't want to have that hard
conversation so they oversimplify
remember the
podcast i just did with t nguyen
which was great i was really happy with
the reception to that podcast it was it
didn't do great numbers it wasn't a big
box office famous person or anything but
everyone who listened to it really
really liked it and it's it's clear why
it's really gives you insight
uh onto the gamification of the world
and one of the points that he makes is
there's a seductiveness to clarity to
too much clarity to to being in
situations where you make things simple
right that's yummy and we like it it's
not necessarily good or true or right
but it's extremely
seductive we want that's what games give
us like we know when you win when you
lose and the real world is messier that
way
so anyway there are fellow pro-free
speech people who just make it about the
freedom of the speech without ever
referring to what the speech is about
right and you can
the the the tell
in my mind is when they say oh look this
person is being denied their free speech
rights for something they did but they
don't tell you what they did
that's the problem they say oh this
person said something politically
incorrect or you know they're being
censored for their views which are
thought to be heterodox without ever
telling you what their views are i think
that's always a mistake that's always
cheating they're trying to get cheap
points from pretending to be pro-free
speech without doing the real work of
explaining what exactly the speech is
that they're defending
did this person
uh make a website saying hitler didn't
go far enough you know that's something
that you know maybe you do want to
prevent that person from giving a talk
because there's probably other people
that could talk on the same subject who
do not think that we should kill all the
jews
um
or maybe you don't maybe you think that
yeah that that person wants one of the
holocaust to go further and yet we
should still listen to him that's fine
if that's your point of view then tell
me that's your point of view but don't
just say for their views without telling
me what their views are that's cheating
so
what i'm saying is we have to confront
the substance of these debates you can't
cheat by making it purely procedural
of course i'm sidestepping for the
moment but let me just mention all the
really difficult questions about
specifically censorship on social media
because i made the analogy to newspapers
and so forth but that analogy only goes
so far it doesn't go all the way i'm
completely on board with admitting that
um there's a difference between a
newspaper and social media newspapers
don't pretend to let everyone have a
voice right whereas social media kind of
do pretend that in some way
and so the standards might very well be
different
um
you know if i do not say anything
horribly offensive or whatever i can go
on twitter and just ramble on forever
and ever and no one stops me that's
different than with my local newspaper i
could not write you know endless pages
and put them in my local newspaper just
because they were inoffensive
and also social media are relatively few
in number right uh we don't have as many
social media platforms as we used to
have local newspapers
so
you can imagine
that we need to invent new rules for
social media that balance the
um
interests of making sure there's no you
know crimes being committed or people
being literally very hurt
versus free speech rights etc and so my
point is just that yeah these are
difficult things to balance um right now
there's very little
government regulation of the social
media relative to what there could be at
least here in the united states i know
some other countries have a lot of
government regulation but i could
imagine an argument that you should
start treating social media kind of like
utilities kind of like the phone company
or whatever right and have some
uh written down laws that tell us what
what kinds of speech are absolutely
protected on these platforms and what
kinds of speech the platform company has
the right to exclude you know legally
right now
it's a private company they can do what
they want roughly speaking that's a
great oversimplification but that's
roughly the rule and uh
maybe you could imagine just
letting it all be capitalist right as
long as there's many many companies
competing with each other they can have
their own rules and you can go into
whatever platform you want but i think
that ignores the reality of the sort of
uh winner takes all nature of these
social media platforms you know you want
to be on the same platform that your
friends are on right it's not just you
can switch painlessly so i think it's
complicated and i think the first step
to making progress on these issues is
admitting what the complications are and
facing up to the fact that they will
there will be balancing acts involved
rather than just saying oh here's my
simple procedure that solves all the
problems and i don't need to worry about
all the actual things that these people
are saying because i have rules that are
very simple right very very seductive
very very yummy point of view but one
that we have to
do better then we can do better than
that
tom hawkins says what are your thoughts
on de-extinctioning
using technology to bring back and
reintroduce extinct species that's a
good question i haven't thought about
the implications very deeply once again
i think
here i am i think the whole the theme of
the ama is i say i haven't thought about
this and then i babble on about it for
10 minutes but i won't babble on uh
about 10 minutes for this one
um
i i i think i'm less against it than
some people are and less for it than
some people are now that i say it that
doesn't sound very fascinating so i
don't think there's any intrinsic virtue
to de-extinctioning in other words i
think that just because a species went
extinct and therefore we lost a little
bit of ecological diversity it is
necessarily good to bring it back right
even if it was made extinct by we human
beings um on the other hand i don't
think there's any necessary vice to it
either you know there's a there's a
school of thought that imagines maybe
without putting in quite these words but
that thinks of the ecosystem as
something that has a natural correct
state of being and we human beings
messing with it is almost always wrong
and i don't i don't believe that either
i think that you know the environment
the ecosystem uh all the different
diversity of life that we have
has to be thought of as dynamic right
it has to be thought of something that
will always change with time species
will go extinct uh new species will be
created and so all of which is to say
it's not necessarily okay when we
extinguish a species but that
never letting any species go extinct
can't be the goal either
and that's one consideration the other
consideration is of course there is
always a law of unintended consequences
especially in these horribly complex
systems like ecosystems
when you try to bring in a new species
you might completely disrupt the lives
of the existing species in ways that you
had not anticipated
so even though i would not be
dead set against doing it i'd be
extraordinarily cautious about it right
i mean there's a coolness to thinking
that we can bring back the woolly
mammoth people always want to bring back
you know charismatic megaphone they're
never worried about bringing back tiny
little insects or anything like that um
so i do worry that there's a bit of
hubris involved on the parts of
individual scientists who think it'd be
cool to bring back the mammoth or
whatever
but i'm not dead set against it either
you know if we if we thought that um
there was some specific harm that had
been done especially by human activity
that had resulted in the extinction of
some species and we could somehow bring
them back or try to bring them back i
don't think there's any necessary
barrier barrier against that and we
should take the possibility very
seriously as i said before in the last
ama when we gain as human beings the
ability to do things we generally do
them
so as much as we want to talk about it
yak yak yak uh here on amas and podcasts
i suspect it will happen in some cases
so
dealing with it will be the bigger
question than should we do it
graff says
you occasionally comment on ideas that
you and your graduate students have
worked on that don't pan out is there
any consistency in the time or effort it
takes to realize that you've hit a dead
end are we talking a few hours weeks
years of time effort and does it ever
make sense to publish the results of
these unsuccessful investigations
um
a really good question because the
answer is no it's not very systematic
it's not very consistent
you know sometimes literally within a
day or a week you realize yeah that
wasn't a very good idea we shouldn't
really be moving in that direction other
times it will literally be more than a
year i've totally gone
working on a project for a year and at
the end going uh it's just not going
where we wanted to um sometimes you're
lucky and that you have an idea that is
that is not really this is how it's
going to be but your idea is here's a
question that we can answer
and whatever the answer is it's
interesting like this model works or
this model doesn't work but in a lot of
work for theoretical physics um what
you're doing is you're proposing a model
or you know some particular take on some
particular issue and if it doesn't work
then no one wants to hear about it right
i mean an experiment that says we're
looking for this effect and we didn't
find it that's useful information to the
rest of the world but a theory where you
say here's an idea we had and it was bad
that is less useful information i mean
maybe you could imagine the compendium
of wrong ideas that people could leave
through um so they would not waste their
time chasing down the same wrong ideas
but that's kind of not very practical in
the real world so yeah for theorists
like myself most of the time when we
come up with an id and it does not pan
out it just goes unpublished there are
absolutely times i think i've said where
it didn't pan out temporarily and then
five years later i come back to an idea
and a twist on it comes up um or you
know i have an idea and i'm just not
quite able to carry it out like i had an
idea when i was a graduate student
about you know if inflation ended a
little bit earlier on one side of the
universe than the other side okay what
would that look like what would that
tilt in the universe look like
um in the sky
but um i didn't have the technological
know-how at the time to actually answer
that question that was a good question
we could write i could write papers on
it but uh i was not an expert at
predicting you know the cmb or anything
like that the cmb no one was an expert
or very few people jim peels was an
expert back at the time when i was
thinking about this but it was not a
whole industry like there is now and um
so i don't know more than 20 years later
um
i wrote a paper on that kind of idea
with adrian arrow jack and mark
heminkowski adrian was a grad student at
caltech at the time she did almost all
the work um and she had that technology
and there was actually a motivation for
doing it because there was acclaimed uh
which might even still be true acclaimed
power and isotropy in the universe where
there seemed to be slightly higher
fluctuations in one hemisphere than the
other hemisphere it turns out to be
really really hard to explain it this is
why science is hard you know we learned
so much about the universe in the
meantime that having the idea is not
enough you have to show that it's
compatible with all sorts of different
data and we have a lot of data now and
so we had to make a somewhat baroque
model
and even then uh it's really close to
the edge of being ruled out by data so
by now maybe i don't know this is a few
years ago so by now maybe
it has been who knows but anyway the
point is there can be a long gestation
time between uh
idea coming up an idea being published
both ideas that work out and ideas that
don't
ingrid gorman says recently i watched a
lecture on youtube where you discuss the
idea of god and compared this with
physics i was interested because you
dwelled on religion and dogma human
constructs and not the fundamental idea
of a creator
would you be willing to just focus on
that particular notion the universe has
a creator it seems we have a few options
to consider there's a creator god who is
infinite and created the universe for
many universes
the universe started itself through
quantum fluctuations or the universe had
always existed therefore there will
always be mysteries my question is can
you consider a creator of matter or the
universe you know this is going to be a
vague answer but
sure i can consider it
consider all sorts of things
i'm not sure exactly what lecture you
watched it probably i would guess it was
the one called god is not a good theory
and i wouldn't say that i was comparing
the idea of god to physics i was i was
taking seriously the idea of god as an
explanatory idea okay in other words you
could have god as something which you
think exists and maybe um has some role
in your life you know helping you get it
through the day etc
but there's a separate idea of god as
something that helps us explain either
the existence of the universe or certain
features of the universe or so forth and
to the extent
that you attribute to god explanatory
powers
you can also evaluate god as a
scientific theory right because you're
saying okay there's some feature of the
world that i see
and i'm giving the explanation of that
over to god well so is it a good
explanation or not does it fit the data
is it simple are there alternative
explanations these are all things that
we would ask about a scientific theory
we can ask them about theism just as
well and that was a point i was trying
to make and of course once you do that
it doesn't work very well it's not a
very good theory compared to other
theories we have so
i'm 100 uh you know happy to consider
the possibility i think there's a lot of
reasons why the possibility does badly i
think there's reasons both of uh in
principle it does badly i think that
it's cheating to say well you know
uh the universe needs a cause
but we can say that causes god and god
doesn't need a cause i think it's a
hundred percent cheating you know you
invented a metaphysical principle that
everything needs a a cause and then you
said accept god because god is a
necessary being 100 cheating i think
that's not really playing fair but also
there are empirical
problems i think that if you take the
idea of god seriously and try to say
that god is the explanation for this and
that feature of the universe then you
should play the game
correctly and consistently and try to
say what are the predictions you would
make about what features the universe
should have under that hypothesis and
that's where what you find i argue is
that the actual features the universe
has are very different than the features
you would predict if god actually was
responsible for them
vladimir belik says what are ariel and
caliban like in terms of their
personalities also any stories about
them would be very welcome my wife and i
are proud cat owners of two cheddar and
tofu
love this question this is exactly the
question i'm always hoping for here in
the amas questions about the kitties
ariel and caliban as long time listeners
know
uh
the companions of jennifer and i we were
foster fails as the saying goes that is
to say we were foster parents for ariel
and caliban when they were
rescues at a local cat shelter so we got
them when they were four weeks old which
is too young to be taken away from your
mommy when you're a kitten
but there's no choice when the mommy's
not there when you're rescued off the
street and so we were just supposed to
you know take care of them with lots of
personal affection until they could be
returned to the shelter but of course
they were too cute and they never went
back so they're still with us now four
years later uh and it's fascinating
because they're brother and sister and
they like each other very much but their
personalities are different and i
mentioned this on the show before you
know ariel is more of a thinker
not that she's necessarily smarter but
you know she contemplates what's going
on she's more you know she's the one who
in classic cat fashion if you open the
door will think about whether she really
wants to go through that door like what
would it involve
whereas caliban just lives in the moment
like he wants things he wants them now
he's either happy or unhappy those are
the only two states caliban is a spin
one-half particle he only has two basic
states and he's usually happy
to be fair
and they what's amazing to me is less
their personalities than their
idiosyncrasies like they have habits
which are just different and bizarre and
i don't know where they come from um you
know caliban
likes to be downstairs that's where he
thinks is his domain and ariel likes to
be upstairs that's where she thinks is
her domain and so every night when we go
to sleep um we go upstairs that's where
the bedroom is and caliban
for a long time he just stayed
downstairs and despite the fact that
he's a big cat he's like 15 pounds of
cat and he's not fat it's muscle
um but his meow is actually a very high
pitched little meep so you would just
hear this little meeping from downstairs
like he didn't understand why you
abandoned him and
we kept explaining to him you know years
have gone by we have never come
downstairs at midnight to hang out with
caliban but he still hopes that that's
what's going to happen more recently
he's developed a compromise where he
will go upstairs where my office is not
he won't go all the way to the bedroom
but he'll go into the office and he'll
just flop onto his belly looking for
belly rubs so he gets his pre-bedtime
belly rubs that makes him happy enough
to um carry on whereas ariel stays with
us all night
uh bedtime is her favorite time but then
in the morning she wants a shower and
this is i know weird cat behavior but we
need to put the shower head on just
trickle so gives a couple drops per
second uh it has to be exactly right and
then she will sit underneath it and let
the drips come on to her body and lick
them off she you know maybe she gets
hydration this way or some way but it's
a hundred percent necessary every
morning and she'll be very vocal if
you're not giving her her shower and
usually in the afternoon or evening as
well she needs an evening shower also i
don't know where they get this it's a
very it's a very weird thing they grew
up in exactly identical circumstances
you know nature certainly matters as
well as nurture even when jennifer
brought them back from the shelter when
they were four weeks old um they had
different responses to being in the cat
carrier and the car and everything it's
kind of amazing and it's very they're
both also very affectionate cats we
clearly have the best kitties in the
world they like being with us
for better for worse they like a lot of
attention they'll spend time uh on our
laps if that's the only choice next to
us on a blanket is even better that's
what they really want out of life
getting the occasional scratches
nate says is it theoretically possible
to build some kind of thermodynamic
engine that uses the cosmological
expansion to do useful work
i think roughly speaking the answer is
no i don't want to say anything too
definitively here because it's always
possible there's some clever
construction i haven't thought of and i
don't know of any theorems
to this effect but
it's this is not 100 true either but
it's a very good uh thing to keep in
mind the cosmological expansion is
similar in many ways
to what you would have if space time
itself were not expanding
but matter was just moving apart right
as if from an explosion where the matter
nearby is moving very slowly the matter
far away is moving fast
so the sort of energy in the expansion
can be thought of as just from the fact
that things are moving apart from each
other right so
sure there's some energy there if you
have two things that are moving apart
and somehow you attach a spring to them
or something you can put energy into the
spring by letting them move apart but
it's not very
obviously it's not very practical in the
case of galaxies or anything like that
but it's just a finite amount of energy
you're going to get it's not just some
limitless supply or anything like that
so
maybe to that extent uh you could
extract energy from it but it's just the
same as extracting energy from two
things moving apart
michael koppelman says i read something
deeply hidden
and i'm confused because you go from the
world must be in a state of
superposition to there are many many
worlds being created all the time it
seems like you skip a step can we think
of no other way for the world to be in a
state of superposition um
so i don't want to be too snarky here
but i'm not quite sure that you read
something deeply hidden or more likely i
did a very bad job of explaining things
because of course you don't go
from the world might be in a state of
superposition to their many worlds being
created all the time uh the missing step
is the schrodinger equation which i
recall i talk about a great length in
something deeply hidden
of course if in quantum mechanics if you
think that
electrons or other subatomic particles
can be in superpositions for example
superpositions of spin up and spin down
and you believe that the whole universe
obeys the rules of quantum mechanics
then you should be able to believe that
the whole universe can be in a
superposition
if that's all that you were saying in
many worlds is that we can contemplate
the world being in superpositions
superpositions of different states that
are completely unrelated to each other
and uh are disconnected and therefore
qualify as separate worlds that would be
incredibly uninteresting no one would
care i mean you live in one world and
that doesn't have anything to do with
the other worlds etc what's important is
that the schrodinger equation tells you
how the wave function evolves
and it evolves from
having only one world in it to having
multiple worlds in it that's how you
resolve the measurement problem in many
worlds uh the measurement problem is
just evolution under the schrodinger
equation nothing mystical nothing
involving consciousness or anything like
that
it's just
tiny microscopic systems that are in a
quantum superposition becoming entangled
with the wider world
and cohering
and that would be the origin of now two
parts of the superposition that you
would actually qualify as separate
worlds so it's the shorting revolution
and the existence of decoherence that
connects the potential existence of
multiple branches of the wave function
to the fact that they actually do appear
in the natural evolution of things
uh anonymous says do you prefer
commuting by train or car
as i.e boston versus la uh yeah cause in
boston where i am now i certainly
commute by subway all the time whereas
when i'm in la it's the car uh there are
subways and public transport in la
but they're not as convenient and the
bus system in la is actually very good
but i'm not very much a bus system and
again it's not convenient for where i
need to go
um
i'm a big believer in public
transportation i enjoy it quite a bit
you know uh parking is always annoying
and driving your own car is kind of
annoying but it needs to be convenient
i'm not someone who thinks that there's
some moral superiority in taking public
transportation i'm someone who thinks
that cities and communities should
design public transportation so that
people want to take it so that it is the
easier more convenient thing to do as it
is for me right now in boston when i was
planning on where to stay in boston when
i came uh but the first consideration
was is it on the red line because the
red line for those of you who know is
the subway train uh that goes by both
harvard and mit for that matter as well
as coming downtown uh to boston so it's
very convenient
almost anywhere in boston you're close
to some subway line but if you have to
like take one line and then get off and
switch and take another one it adds
quite a bit to the journey and to the
inconvenience i i did you know i lived
uh for a while when i was a postdoc at
mit i lived in the south end and needed
to switch um and it was about 50 50
whether i would take the subway or walk
it's about half an hour trip either way
from my place to mit
some days in boston it is cold enough
that you do not want to walk especially
when that walk involves crossing the
charles river when it is uh very windy
and chilled so what i would like i guess
i don't care about commuting by train or
by car i like you know driving too
there's there are pleasures in that um
all else being equal i would rather
commute by train because you know you
can think you don't need to pay
attention to the road it's better for
the environment all that stuff
but only if it is convenient only if the
system has uh organized itself so that
public transportation is good not uh
just because i think it's the right
thing to do
emmett francis says how would you define
the physics of democracy would it
include most types of mathematical
models for political systems or only
those originally developed for other
physics
you know i think uh i do
i'm working on a book on the physics of
democracy which is where the question
comes from um it's gonna take a while to
write i have these other books to write
in the meantime
um so i've been thinking about what it
means and you know my plan for the book
is to take an extremely expansive view
of what the physics of democracy is so
the math of democracy
definitely counts
um
and you know yeah i i'm not going to be
too persnickety about whether or not a
particular idea was originally developed
by other by for physics purposes or
something like that what i want to do is
just take the point of view that people
are physical systems
that's true um and they uh have some
properties and they interact with each
other and they come together to form
collective behavior and emergent
behavior and there's certain universal
properties of how that happens and so
you can ask questions about um
self-organization and stratification and
inequality and also decision making and
voting and the extent to which a you
know collective decision can
represent some coarse-grained or
renormalized view of the individual
decisions of people in it and all those
philosophical ideas um about what you
mean when you say a democracy have
direct analogs in physics phase
transitions
non-linearities catastrophe theory
people changing their minds
fluctuations uh
the role of unpredictability you know
many many things are ideas that are
common
both to the physics of
complex systems and also to
societies democracies and otherwise but
democracies in particular because
democracies have this sort of bottom-up
bubbling up decision-making process so
i'm going to count all that as the
physics of democracy whatever is most
interesting and enlightening for the
book is what's going to count for me
josh hedgepeth says last year julian
barbour came out with a new book the
janus point where he seems to present an
idea similar to those you explored in
your book from eternity to hear how does
his idea contrast with the ideas you
explored in your book
yeah i mean there's definitely a family
resemblance there so i think that both
of our ideas can be thought of as on two
different levels one is the very
abstract level of you know what is the
mechanism
what is the general big picture idea
you're taking advantage of um and the
other level is what is the specific
implementation of that idea of that big
picture idea and so you know julian and
i have emailed back and forth about this
because uh uh jennifer chen and i
made this point a long time ago back in
2004 and i've elaborated it in talks and
other short articles since then that if
you have a system that is eternal in
time
um
but only sort of has a finite number of
moving pieces
so sorry let me get that let me get that
better let me say it correctly i don't
say this often enough um you need a
system that is both eternal in time and
unbounded in configuration space so if
you have a system that is eternal in
time but only has a bounded set of
things it can do then it will just
repeat right then there's only a finite
number of things it can do we'll do them
over and over again it has no choice
um likewise you can imagine a system
that is sort of a hybrid where there's
an infinite number of things that can
happen but in any one region there's
only a finite number of things that can
happen like if you have an infinite if
you forget about general relativity just
have an infinite box of gas right um the
gas has some uniform background
fluctuations but it still will sort of
cycle through the different
possibilities that possibility is a
little bit mathematically undefined and
we're not sure what to do about it but
it's out there finally if you have like
a finite number of particles
uh in an infinitely big universe for an
infinite amount of time
then you always get an arrow of time
automatically okay and that was part of
the point that jennifer and i made and i
like i said i said it again and again
and um
julian barber was in the audience during
talks when i said it and so i i think
and this this is completely acceptable
and it happens all the time i think
julian came up with that idea
what he thought of as independently um
because he was thinking about something
completely different he was thinking
about his idea about shape dynamics and
you know a way of thinking about gravity
and so forth and he realized that this
this feature of being able to expand
being able basically to
have a minimum
amount of entropy in some configuration
and then very naturally increase in
entropy in both directions of time
toward what one person would call the
past and they would call the future or
vice versa so that the what he calls the
janus point is this midpoint of entropy
but
the whole point is that the system as a
whole has a sort of parabolic or at
least u-shaped plot of entropy versus
time where there's a very natural
minimum point from which entropy
increases in both directions again that
was part of
jenny chen's and my model it's also part
of his uh i don't think that he
necessarily got it from me but we were
there first and i think he does
recognize that the specific
implementation of it is completely
different there's no overlap so you know
his model is completely different than
ours his model is actually more sort of
classical quasi-newtonian gravity in the
in this um sort of uh shape dynamics
formalism that he likes to use whereas
jenny and i were trying to be much more
speculative and talk about inflation and
quantum tunneling into baby universes
and all this stuff um so i think both
aspects are interesting the overall
framework and the specific
implementation you know our
implementation was on the one hand much
more speculative on the other hand
at least tried to get the real world
right you know our even though our
speculative idea involves a lot of leaps
of faith in terms of known physics at
the end of the day if it's right it
predicts the kind of universe we live in
whereas what julian and his
collaborators are working with is much
more of a toy model like a principal uh
demonstration in principle that
something like this can happen so i
think it's you know the in spirit this
ideas are very compatible but two very
different implementations thereof
herbert berkowitz says i've been
watching the moving naturalism forward
videos and i've been struck by how often
various panelists refer to data as
granular or coarse grained what does
that mean is there not enough data is it
too vague it just does something that's
crunchy
so it just means that we take some of
the data but it doesn't i guess it
doesn't just mean that it means that
there is a subset of all the data about
a system so you're imagining a system
that it has many moving parts many
particles making it up or whatever it is
and there is some comprehensive
microscopic explanation so there's some
way to write down literally exactly what
the system is doing okay but the course
grain description doesn't
take into account all of the data it
says of all the possible different
configurations of this microscopic
comprehensive description let's group
them together because we can observe
certain maybe because we can observe or
just as convenient to talk about certain
features of them so the classic example
is
fluid dynamics or thermodynamics where
you say of course there are atoms and
molecules underneath the surface i don't
know what all the atoms and molecules
are doing but i can coarse grain by
saying that there is a temperature and a
pressure and a velocity for the fluid
and it turns out
that even though the amount of
information contained
in that specification of temperature
pressure velocity etc is much less
than the amount of information contained
in literally writing down the position
and velocity of every atom
nevertheless you get a highly predictive
theory that's what emergence is all
about the ability to coarse grain that
is to say to only take into
consideration some very tiny subset of
all the data and nevertheless get a
theory that tells you something useful
about how the system evolves over time
that's what people were talking about
george cervinka says near the end of the
biggest ideas in the universe number 15
on gauge theory
you say about the weak force that
symmetry is both preserved and
spontaneously broken the mexican hat
shows potential energy as non-zero at t
equals zero and then it rolls down to
zero potential energy at many points
please restate which symmetry exactly is
preserved which is broken and what
exactly is spontaneous about the
breaking so for those of you who have
not seen the biggest ideas in the
universe video number 15
this is a very standard presentation of
spontaneous symmetry breaking in
particular spontaneous gauge symmetry
breaking there is a difference i'm not
going to go into it right here but gauge
theories and what we call global
symmetry theories are very different in
their dynamics and their predictions
so the weak interactions are a gauge
symmetry that has been spontaneously
broken and so it's actually helpful to
think of you know why we ever thought of
this in the first place you know back in
the 50s let's say
people were very excited about the
success of quantum electrodynamics right
qed and for that matter they were
excited about the success of classical
electrodynamics which was 100 years
older but still very successful uh it
seemed to be a paradigm for a good way
to do particle physics photons and
electrons and all that stuff
and the photons had this theory that
maxwell invented and was elaborated on
in the quantum context that involves
gauge symmetry
a symmetry that exists at every point in
space-time separately that's what gauge
means at this in this example
so there was a very natural idea look we
have other forces of nature like the
nuclear forces the strong force the weak
force maybe their gauge symmetries also
and people like yang and mills
showed us how you can generalize the
idea of electromagnetism to more
complicated gauge symmetry theories
maybe somehow those are good theories of
the strong interactions or the weak
interactions but there is a problem
gauge invariance
seems to prevent
the particle excitations of these new
fields you're inventing from having mass
it predicts very strongly that the
particles should be massless and in fact
that's true in the case of the photon or
even in the case of the graviton in
gravity which is not exactly the same
but highly analogous there's a gauge
symmetry there also
and so it seems that if you have a gauge
theory you have massless particles but
we know that the strong interactions and
or we thought we knew strong
interactions in the weak interactions do
not have massless particles because
massless particles give rise to forces
that extend infinitely far
and the nuclear forces don't extend
infinitely far they're short-range
forces
so spontaneous symmetry breaking
pioneered by nambu and goldstone and
then elaborated on by people like
anderson and brow and anglair and higgs
and others
was all about this idea that if you have
some other field
we now call it the higgs field
and this other field is involved in the
symmetry so it feels the symmetry
transformation in some sense but then
rather than being zero in the vacuum
it's not zero in the vacuum that can
appear to spontaneously break the
symmetry and so this is a long-winded uh
backgrounder to george's question
which is that
we talk about spontaneous symmetry
breaking but really if you really are
careful about defining all your words
etc
when you spontaneously break a gauge
symmetry it's not broken at all you
can't break a gauge symmetry a gauge
symmetry when you really dig into what
it is it's just a redundancy of
description it's like coordinate
invariance right
you're always allowed to choose whatever
coordinates you want so for example in
you will often read the completely
incorrect claim that special relativity
can't deal with accelerated particles
special relativity only tells you about
inertial or straight line unaccelerated
particles that's completely bs
special relativity has no problem
whatsoever dealing with accelerated
particles what is meant is that there is
a preferred system of reference frames
in special relativity namely inertial
reference frames so
physics looks simpler in those
coordinate systems in special relativity
but that doesn't mean it's impossible to
talk about
accelerated frames or whatever you can
use whatever coordinate system you want
likewise when you have a spontaneously
broken gauge symmetry
so the mexican hat comes in because the
potential energy for the higgs field
looks like a sombrero that is to say at
zero it's sitting on top of a little
peak and the bottom of the potential
energy function looks like the brim of a
hat and what that means is that the
symmetry is rotating the hat you know
the hat looks completely the same if you
rotate it so that's symmetry right there
but if the field is sitting at the top
of the hat at the middle at zero
that field value itself is invariant
under the symmetry the whole hat is
always invariant under the symmetry but
the value of the field if it's at zero
doesn't change when you rotate the hat
whereas if the field is sitting in the
brim of the hat it's not spread out all
over the brim it's sitting at some point
in the brim of the hat and then even
though the hat as a whole is invariant
under the symmetry you're moving the
field you're changing the value of the
field if you rotate the hat
we call that spontaneous symmetry
breaking but really the symmetry is not
broken the symmetry is hidden
from you because you you don't think
about changing the value of the field
the value of the field is just hidden
there in the background you don't see it
so sometimes people talk about hidden
symmetries or something like that or
even non-linearly realized symmetries
the upshot is that once you have that
value of the higgs field that is not
zero
it no longer is true that the bosons of
the field must be massless in fact the w
and z bosons of the weak interactions
can get a mass
so again you thought you had a symmetry
that prevented particles from getting a
mass but they can get a mass so you say
ah the symmetry is broken but the more
correct thing to say is the symmetry is
hidden uh the the symmetry itself is
literally a choice of
how i put coordinates on on this mexican
hat clearly i'm allowed to put whatever
coordinates on the hat that i want but
putting the coordinates where the field
is at zero where i live is more
convenient so we think of that as a
manifestation of the hiddenness of the
symmetry okay
gauta einevol says a priority question
like many with physics training i find
your poetic naturalist outlook as
described in the big picture to be both
sensible and appealing everything we see
is at a fundamental level described by
the core theory of particle physics but
this does not prevent us from talking
about phenomena in the macroscopic world
using other terms such as temperature or
chair
however from what i understand you also
believe that the hard problem of
consciousness eventually can be
explained by weak immersions starting
with the laws of physics for me it just
seems a priori impossible to derive an
inside out perspective what it feels
like to be me
from the outside in perspective inherent
in physics types descriptions i cannot
even think of what a derivation could
look like you seem to be less daunted by
this do you have any insights to add to
make me feel less daunted um i mean this
is the right question to ask this is
exactly the
position that a lot of people have that
leads them to deny that the known laws
of physics are going to be up to the
task of explaining consciousness they
can't imagine
what such an explanation would look like
um
i mean if i'm snarky about it why should
i care what you can imagine and not
you know our imaginations might not be
up to the task that is not that is very
very far short of a proof
um and i think that the evidence in
favor of the essential correctness of
the core theory of physics is big enough
that whether i can imagine how to
come up with an explanation of the first
person perspective or not uh doesn't
daunt me it's not going to lead me to
think that i'm going to overthrow the
laws of physics if i'm less snarky about
it
to be honest i don't see the
impossibility of uh imagining a
description here uh i mean there is a
linguistic thing going on where you're
choosing to describe what happens in the
world in terms of your first person
experience right like i am experiencing
the redness of red or whatever you want
to say
but there is if you're a poetic
naturalist that
set of words i'm experiencing the
redness of red is a higher level
emergent description of some collection
of particles and fields acting in some
way so it's not that it replaces the
particles and fields or the particles
and field replace your experience it's
just there are two different ways of
talking about the same thing so the
question to ask is can you imagine a
collection of particles and fields that
would be led to
have all of the behaviors that we
associate with having conscious
experiences right with saying i am
experiencing the redness of red with
writing books about consciousness that
say it can't be physical because i have
first person experiences and i have zero
problem imagining that a bunch of
particles and fields would do that i i
don't see what the obstacle is the only
obstacle appears if somehow you're
persuaded that
a priori in fact i think do you use the
words abriari sorry i don't know uh in
the question um but if you're persuaded
yeah you say a priori impossible uh
that that when there exists a person
named me saying that i am experiencing
the redness of red that they're it's a
priory impossible that the true
experience that is happening there
can be thought of as
a way of talking about the behavior of
some atoms and molecules i just don't
see that in possibility at all i
i i don't even know where it comes from
why i would imagine that that is
impossible um
i'm experiencing the redness of red that
is a way of talking about the what is
happening to the atoms and molecules in
my brain i just don't see the leap there
whatsoever it seems pretty
straightforward honestly to me that
doesn't mean it'll be easy to figure out
um because what we want is a real
uh understanding of what parts of the
brains are doing what things what kinds
of actions and and uh
firings of neurons correspond to you
thinking that you're experiencing breath
etc and that's gonna be very very
difficult to find out but this is why i
think that the hard problem is not going
to be solved it's just going to
evaporate
if we had a 100
thorough and reliable and comprehensive
understanding of which
purported consciousness experience
corresponded to which things happening
in the brain i think we would just
declare victory we'd say we're done
that's all there is to be explained
and if you want a stronger argument i
mean i'm trying to you know be fair and
actually confront the
objection you raised but the stronger
counter argument is
um
look either you're going to violate the
laws of physics somehow even if either
you're going to say i want to change the
laws of physics which fine you're
welcome to do that but there's a huge
conceptual um prejudice against doing
that because there's a lot of
experimental evidence and theoretical
reasons why the laws of physics should
be left alone
or
you're saying well i need something
additional in my ontology
in order to explain consciousness but
that additional stuff has no effect on
the behavior of stuff in the universe
and i think that just is not answering
the question that you're purporting to
answer you know if literally this extra
part of your ontology or your
modification of existing ontology
um
is supposed to be explaining what i mean
when i say the redness of red
but it has no effect on me saying that i
experience the redness of red then i
think it is not actually explaining that
so i think that you know there's a
dilemma and both horns of the dilemma
are extremely unpalatable and avoiding
the dilemma means saying eventually
we're going to explain consciousness in
terms of a weakly emerging collection of
particles
talking about the redness of red
alexandra bates says do you believe the
following statement from sabina
hassenfelder girdle's theorem is
irrelevant for scientific practice
that's because one can always extend the
original set of axioms with another
axiom that simply says whether or not
the previously undecidable statement is
true
well yes and no i
do agree mostly with the first part the
statement that girdle's theorem is
irrelevant for scientific practice the
word practice is doing a lot of work
there but in practice literally in
practice i have never worried about
girdle's theorem in doing science i've
never even worried about worrying about
it um i don't know anyone who's ever
worried about it like there's no point
in doing physics where you say well
maybe i won't the answer be able to
answer this question because of girdle's
theorem it's not even the kind of thing
that would potentially worry you because
girdle's theorem is a statement of what
can be proven inside some formal system
and science is not about proving things
so who cares um the second part of
sabine's um
statement i i
i don't necessarily have the exact quote
here i decided what you wrote but i
don't think that that sounds exactly
right i mean the reason why i don't care
about girdle's theorem is not because
i can always extend the original set of
axioms
um i mean there's problematic things
about that statement even within
mathematical logic but more importantly
who cares i don't want to prove things
that's not what i do in science what i
do in science is i propose hypotheses
and i test them
and i evaluate credences based on the
fit of the hypotheses to the data and
their simplicity and fruitfulness and
compatibility with other ideas that i
have and so forth and so on none of
which is proving theorems right i mean
girdle's theorem is is irrelevant to me
because i'm not proving theorems that's
all i would say
jason hale says
if you could talk to boer einstein
heisenberg what would be the biggest
advance that would inform their thinking
on quantum mechanics since their time
um i think the answer is pretty
obviously a better understanding of
decoherence you know i mean maybe there
were some hints in heisenberg and
schrodinger they that they knew
something about it but there clearly was
not a systematic understanding
and i think that largely the reason why
there wasn't is because the whole
copenhagen philosophy of borin
heisenberg largely shut off
investigations into it and einstein you
know with his epr paper tried to uh make
people think carefully about
entanglement and they chose not to
until john bell started thinking
carefully about it and then people like
constituted say in the 1970s really
developed a theory of decoherence and
even then when owensay tried to publish
his papers he had a lot of trouble
getting them published because people
didn't either care or believe him
um and now people like just oh it's
obvious like why do you even bother with
this but you know the point being that
there's two points uh that get you to
caring about decoherence both of which
are just part of quantum mechanics one
is
the idea of the universal wave function
right as everett um
emphasized but is absolutely part of
quantum mechanics from the start there
are not separate wave functions for
different parts of the universe there's
just one wave function for the whole
shebang you may be lucky enough to be in
situations where you can for the moment
separate out the wave function of some
subsystem from something else but in
principle there's just one big wave
function um and the other idea is that
there is the schrodinger equation which
entangles uh subsystems with their
environments right if everything include
is included in the wave function
then that includes all the photons in
the room et cetera et cetera et cetera
and they keep monitoring your tiny
quantum mechanical systems and that is
what we call decoherence because
everything is in the same wave function
and it keeps getting entangled um so
i don't know whether understanding the
coherence very carefully would have
dramatically affected how born einstein
and heisenberg thought about quantum
mechanics but i suspect that it would
have at least changed how they talked
about it
because all of these worries about the
measurement problem and so forth
it's not solved by decoherence you still
need an ontology you still need a good
formulation of quantum mechanics but
whatever the solution is is affected in
a very deep way by d coherence so i
think that would have been important to
them
okay i'm going to group two questions
together because they're very similar
leon bernstein says in the mindscape
interview with priya natarajan you said
that you have a vested interest in the
theory of modified gravity over that of
dark matter why is that and peter crousp
says in your interview with priya
natarajan where you talked about
modifications of dark matter versus
gravity theory you mentioned that you
would prefer the theory of gravity to be
changed which obviously means modifying
einstein's equations is this an outcome
of your own research getting these
equations out of the wave function so
there are two answers to these questions
both the question is why did i say i had
a vested interest in modified gravity
one is it's just cooler right uh gravity
is cool there are things we don't
understand about gravity if um i mean so
far einstein's theory which he invented
in 1915 fits all the data that we have
and if we could find some way in which
uh that theory had to be modified
especially for cosmology that would be
tremendous that would be uh incredibly
helpful to us understanding gravity as
well as understanding cosmology
more and more down to earth level
i have written papers about this my most
cited paper
is proposing a theory a modified theory
of gravity that explains the
acceleration of the universe rather than
dark energy and people are always
surprised when i uh say because you know
in in physics community circles that's
my most famous paper right and so you
know i'm the modified gravity guy but i
always say like no i mean probably the
acceleration of the universe is the
cosmological constant it's not probably
modified gravity uh because this is how
theoretical physics works right like you
propose an idea not because you think
it's true
but because you think it's possibly true
you assign some credence to it right you
think it's worth investigating that's
why you propose a theory
so i don't think that my theory or our
theory since i co-authors but our theory
is probably true just like i don't
necessarily think that my theory with
jennifer chen about the arrow time is
probably true
i think that there's a non-zero
possibility that these things are true
um in the case of the arrow of time i
know of no better theory
as speculative and uh hand-wavy as our
model was i still think it's the best
one i've ever heard whereas in the case
of the acceleration of the universe
there's an obvious better theory just
sitting there namely the cosmological
constant uh so if it turned out that the
acceleration of the universe was
explained by modifying gravity then you
know i'd be happy
for personal reasons but right now given
the data and the theoretical situation i
still think it's kind of unlikely
sandra stuckey says
when and why did you decide to write
your first trade book do you ever doubt
writing such a book was a good idea and
if so what made you do it anyway
you know i was probably for years and
years the kind of person who thought
someday i would write a trade book um i
like writing books i like writing i like
explaining physics i like making
arguments i like you know working at
that boundary where
you're not just speculating you're
working close to what we understand uh
when it comes to my first trade book was
from eternity to here on the arrow of
time and cosmology so i could do a lot
of explaining right i could talk about
boltzmann and maxwell's demon and cups
of coffee and all that stuff
but also i could number one make a point
the point being that explaining why the
early universe had a low entropy it
should be a super duper high priority
goal of modern cosmology and it's not
most cosmologists don't think about that
it would not be on their list of top
five things cosmology should be trying
to explain and i think it should be so
that was the argument i was making
and then number two proposing an answer
to that question you know explaining um
the idea of unbounded entropy and
unbounded evolution of the universe and
what we talked about before when i was
talking about uh julian barber's theory
and the comparison between them um so
anyway
i thought that i always thought that you
know that kind of thing would be a good
idea my honestly my first idea for
writing a trade book was on dark energy
in the accelerating universe
um but by the time i thought to do it
the publishing industry was of the
opinion that that was kind of played out
i'm you know i'm talking here about like
2003.
there's only five years after we
discovered the accelerating universe but
it was in the newspapers all the time
and people thought that you know they've
been talked about enough and i wasn't
proposing a new radical theory right i
was just
going to do a better job of explaining
it in my mind than anyone else had done
and you know the publishing yeah you
know we don't care about that
but what they but my agent said was but
what are you working on what is your
passion right now and it was the arrow
of time so i ended up writing about that
um did i ever doubt it was a good idea
that depends on what you mean by a good
idea um you know it certainly didn't
help me get tenure uh but it was after
um sorry to be to be perfectly fair uh i
didn't write the book until after i'd
already not gotten 10 years so that was
not involved with that kind of decision
uh but it didn't help me
you know be hired by someone else who
would give me tenure either
writing popular books is just never
going to help you along the research
ladder in academia but you know there's
there are balances i i enjoyed doing it
they paid me they didn't pay me a lot it
was my first book um
but
it helped people you know it
when you write your first book there's
an inevitable worry that it's maybe it's
the only book you'll ever write so you
want to say everything
and so that book was the longest book
i've written by quite a stretch and uh
yes you want to like put every little
anecdote and fun little thing in there
and you know that serves a purpose uh to
some extent i'm um it's good that i did
it that way but there are other ways to
do it that would have been shorter and
easier to digest um
so um i didn't think but you know to be
super duper honest to answer the
question i didn't worry about it i
didn't fret about it too much i just
wanted to do it so i did it that's
usually how i get in trouble
james dan caro says
in your new work on complexity and
emergence what is the key discovery or
insight that you expect can be made
so what i care about i'm not saying i've
made any interesting progress on this as
yet but obviously many people have
worked on complexity and emergence and
there's a lot of
work that has been done that you could
read books have been written many many
papers etc
but typically they have a system in mind
right and they're looking at how
emergence happens in that system whereas
what i would like to do is take a step
back and say what are the general
conditions under which emergence happens
what does it mean when we say
emergence happens uh is emergence
generic will it always happen in a wide
variety of theories or do you need a
very special kind of theory what is the
role played by um locality in space and
reversibility and other things that we
think might be true about fundamental
physics et cetera so i think there is a
sort of quasi-philosophical take even
though it's ultimately a more scientific
question you know what are the criteria
you write down
quantitatively and rigorously that will
show you that this theory is a good
approximation within complete data to
this other uh more fine-grained theory
and
people you know there's been some work
done on this but just not enough you
know the the
podcast i recently did with anil seth we
talked about what do you mean by
emergence what are the criteria what are
the rigorous technical quantitative
things you can write down to say yes
this theory has emerged from that theory
so that's the kind of thing that i would
like to better understand
patrick hall says what if anything
distinguishes scientific thinking from
non-scientific thinking i think the
biggest thing probably many things in
practice but the biggest thing in
principle is a sort of fallablistic
attitude where you say i can't just
have some bedrock foundational
principles and reason from them
rather i will put forward guesses
hypotheses we call them
and see whether they're right or wrong
that's one thing and the other thing is
the judgment about whether these
hypotheses are right or wrong is
ultimately empirical right i mean
thought experiments can help you get
there
your your credences can absolutely be
changed by theoretical insights my
favorite example in physics it's not
very well known but it's it's very very
uh vivid for those who care about it is
um the renormalization of spontaneously
broken gauge theories okay so we already
talked a little bit just minutes ago
about
uh the higgs mechanism and breaking
gauge invariants and the weak
interactions
uh what particle physicists know and
it's not always um common knowledge so
higgs and brow and anglair and gorelnick
hagen and kibble who also wrote a
similar paper this is all like 1964
right so they were using the idea of
spontaneous symmetry breaking
to engage theories to help explain what
they thought would be the strong
interactions they were trying to explain
strong interactions those were thought
to be easier to get at than the weak
interactions it turned out to be wrong
they were not going to
the strong interactions have a
completely different
explanation involving asymptotic freedom
and quark confinement and things like
that
um but it was a few years later in 1967
that stephen weinberg
um
there were some similar
ideas from glashow and salaam so they
shared the nobel prize was really
weinberg who got it right and very
explicitly and said look i'm going to
use this idea of the higgs mechanism to
explain the weak interactions
and leptons is what he said right
electrons and neutrinos and so forth
and it was completely ignored like no
one cited his paper from 1967 um it was
an idea it was a model was on the market
there
but one of the reasons why it was
ignored was because at the time in the
1960s the state of quantum field theory
was that people were really really
concerned about renormalizability
renormalizability was this uh criterion
that you could apply to a quantum field
theory
stemming from work um from feynman
schwinger tomonaga in the 40s and 50s on
renormalizing quantum electrodynamics by
renormalizing we mean if you naively
plug things in to your calculations you
get infinite answers but you figure out
a particular technique that gets rid of
the infinities and gives you a finite
answer you can compare with experiment
that seems important right getting a
finite answer you can compare with
experiment so if your theory was not
renormalizable people did not pay
attention to it and the point is that
these spontaneously broken gauge
theories they didn't know
whether they were normalizable or not
it's not there was some data saying yes
or no it's just that no one knew so it
wasn't that popular to think about them
some people were thinking of giving up
on field theory entirely and doing what
was called s matrix theory
and then it was
i think 1972 anyway in the very early
1970s that gerard tuft who was still a
graduate student at the time um he got
some some collaboration with his advisor
uh teeny beltman but mostly by himself
he showed that you could renormalize
spontaneously broken gage theories okay
so 1972 so five years after weinberg's
theory weinberg's paper was written
so we didn't learn anything about the
universe in the sense that we didn't do
an experiment or collect data but
overnight once a tuff showed us that
spontaneously broken gauge theories are
renormalizable
interest in weinberg's theory and
related theories went from zero to one
right it became eventually the most
cited paper in the history of particle
physics it was eventually overtaken by
juan maldasena's ads cft correspondence
but weinberg's model of leptons uh
suddenly became hugely important and in
fact turns out to be right as to how the
leptons actually do work
so
the only thing that changed in 1972 was
um a theoretical insight okay anyway
that's a very long digression to get to
the point that um
scientific thinking is fallibilistic in
the sense that uh
a good experiment can always overturn
your theoretical idea but the footnote
is along the way a good theory can also
either overturn or a theoretical insight
can either boost or squelch the
credences we have in our theories but
ultimately at the end of the day
you have to agree with the data um
weinberg's theory made predictions it
predicted in particular what we call
weak currents sorry weak neutral
currents we already knew there were weak
currents weak currents is just a fancy
way of saying there are w bosons
weinberg's theory predicted there be
another particle the z boson and guess
what they found it they found the
evidence for it that's why he won you
could have the most beautiful theory in
the world if it conflicts the data it's
not going to win
kathy seeger says in the podcast episode
with janae and ismael you briefly
mentioned that you tried out lsd how was
it
yes as part of research for jennifer's
book on the science of self called me
myself and why we took lsd once uh it
was good it was fun you know it was i
haven't done it since and it was many
years ago so
i'm not a regular user and i not have
done any other um major
uh
banned substances of that form but you
know lsd is non-addictive and you don't
even have a hangover the next day it's
extremely
uh benign in that way
um and yeah it you know uh lowers as i
talked about with robin carhart harris
on the podcast you know he's a actual
researcher in psychoactive substances
and the real trick of these substances
is not that they
fire up your brain
and give you all these visions as they
lower the inhibitions in your brain they
sort of lower the filter right so it's
like when i do these podcasts and i have
to run them through
a program to lower the noise in the
background so lsd removes that noise
filter and it shows you all the things
going on that are going on in your brain
all the time um anyway it's not showing
you anything new it's just letting you
see what is going on in your brain so i
did do the one the one reason why i
chose as this as a question to answer is
because i can say one thing which i've
said before but probably not in this
venue
many people you know steve jobs for
example
have said that you know lsd unlocks your
creativity uh makes you see the world in
a different way so i was curious about
that scientifically you know i'm a
theoretical physicist i had various
things i was working on at the time in
my research and so you know i brought
those along with me to think about while
i was on lsd you know would it help me
break through some of the puzzles i was
dealing with
no not at all is the answer to that one
like it is impossible as far as i can
tell to do serious theoretical physics
while on lsd you can't even write down
the equations so what is the point of
that i mean maybe if i had a different
kind of problem that was more
intrinsically visual or something like
that it'd be a different story but for
the kinds of puzzles i was working on no
lsd is of no help
siraj rajan says if you have a second
favorite among the quantum
interpretations that comes close to
explaining all the apparent phenomena
what would it be
i think it's pretty obviously some form
of pilot wave or boaming mechanics kind
of theory so
uh you know the biggest competitors in
the world of quantum interpretations are
everett which you've heard of
pilot wave theories which say that so
sorry everett says the whole world is
described by a quantum state by a wave
function okay and it just only ever
evolves according to the schrodinger
equation and that's it everything else
is just branching and decoherence etc
the pilot wave theories say yes there is
a wave function yes it is real it
describes the world
yes it only and ever evolves according
to the schrodinger equation so far so
good but also there are additional
variables so the wave function is not
the whole story there's additional
variables which we call hidden variables
even though they're the ones you
actually observe
and the point is that the wave function
still evolves according to the
schrodinger equation it is not affected
it's not pushed back on
by the extra variables but the extra
variables are pushed around by the wave
function in such a way they sort of gang
up in regions where the wave function is
big and that's why when you observe them
you tend to observe
large wave function regions but not
necessarily so there's some probable
probability there then other options are
objective collapse models where wave
functions really do collapse in
violation of the schrodinger equation
or
dramatically different models known as
epistemic models where the wave function
is not a description of reality at all
it's just a tool
to be used to make predictions for
things and so
um
my own personal credences are heavily
weighted against epistemic models
because i'm a big believer in the real
world
and among epistemic people who favor
epistemic models you know they they all
think that the wave function is not a
direct representation of the real world
some of them think that because there is
no direct representation of the real
world you shouldn't talk about the real
world you shouldn't talk about objective
reality you should only talk about what
agents observe
others think that well there will be
also a real world but it's not described
by a wave function we don't know what it
is yet either way uh i think is a step
backwards for me and my desire to
understand the real world okay so
maybe someday they'll come up with some
version of the real world that is
compatible with their theory but i
already have a version so why am i going
to worry about that and the spontaneous
collapse model's you know fine but it's
an extra rule of physics that i don't
think is needed and it's very different
than all the other rules the collapse of
the wave function rules it's not
reversible it's not deterministic it's
an ugly duckling in many many ways and
there's no really good version of a
theoretical prediction for how it should
work honestly
so the pilot wave theories are least
objectionable to me um
in fact david deutsch made the witticism
that he thinks that pilot wave theories
are just
many worlds in denial because
you still have a wave function you still
have many branches of the wave function
but you have these extra variables that
are sort of pointing to one of the
branches and saying this is the right
one okay and he's like yeah you still
have the other branches there's still
people living on those other branches
who cares which is the right one
um well i don't know maybe there is some
good reason why having extra variables
that point to the right one is a good
thing on the other hand there's a
obvious very large
difficulty with all those models is that
they just don't play well with modern
physics
you know the the bohmian mechanics
models and then de bruy's model even
earlier than that these were written
down in the context of non-relativistic
point particle quantum mechanics
and people have tried hard to generalize
them to quantum field theory etc but
number one it's hard number two it's not
convincing when it happens number three
it's not even close to representing
things like quantum gravity and emergent
space time i wouldn't know how to do it
right
in my mind both the hidden variable
models and the spontaneous collapse
models
uh get a lot of their mileage out of
smuggling in pre-existing classical
notions of stuff and locations in space
and all this all these things none of
which are going to survive once we
understand quantum gravity and i know
that quantum gravity thinks you know
sounds like an abstract future research
program but gravity exists
and that research program is going to
have to be faced someday and so i'm just
not that interested in doing a
tremendous amount of work that relies on
fundamental incompatibility with
something we know is true about the
universe namely gravity uh again these
are all objections you can overcome none
of these is airtight but in my mind the
things you need to do to overcome them
are extremely awkward and unconvincing
so i'd rather just accept the wave
function for what it is
that's why i think everett is the best
john yara e
says the expansion of the universe is
mainly measured by the redshift of
distance stars galaxies and cosmic
microwave background how sure are we
that other undiscovered phenomena is not
contributing to the redshift a plausible
scenario might be a redshift caused by
moving photons through cold plasma in
between galaxies and losing energy in
the process which may appear as a
redshift to us how plausible is this
scenario
so i will answer your question seriously
in a second but first at the risk of
being snarky let me make a meta comment
here um
when you when you ask a question like
this you know the redshift of distant
galaxies is it possible there's an
alternative explanation other than the
expansion of space
would you really think that cosmologists
have not thought about this
would you really think that
uh modern physicists who are trying
their best to understand the universe
haven't sat down and thought really hard
about all the conceivable ways that you
might explain the cosmic redshift i mean
this is their job this is what we do you
know some vision in which scientists get
an explanation and then stop
is not very accurate it is not a very
good model of how real scientists work
because remember
science makes progress by disproving
someone else's idea
by overthrowing the existing consensus
so if we had the wrong explanation for
cosmic redshift and there was another
one that was better that was based on
more down-to-earth physics it would be
in every single working cosmologist's
interest to find that and publish it and
work on it and show that it was true so
of course people have thought through
this stuff there are many good reasons
to get to the actual answer to your
question why that doesn't work why other
explanations for the cosmological
relationship don't work i mean a simple
one that is appealing to a theorist such
as myself is in general relativity
there will be a redshift or a blue shift
right the universe is either expanding
or contracting those are the only two
choices and so you're gonna have a
redshift already uh unless the universe
is contracting which in which case
there'll be a blue shift so we have an
explanation there it is it's it's a it's
a necessary part of our modern
understanding of the universe
but maybe there are other things that
make some contribution to it what you
would do then as a good scientist is to
say well what is the difference what is
the empirical difference between saying
there's a redshift because of the
expansion of the space versus a redshift
because of interaction with some matter
in the universe and they are different
for example the redshift because of the
expansion of space comes along with a
time dilation right in general
relativity
you can literally think of the redshift
as expanding the amount of time spent
between different peaks of the
electromagnetic wave that is coming to
you and that means that other things
have amount of time dilation also like
the light curve of a supernova so when
you look at a supernova and it's
redshifted by a certain amount if the
relativistic explanation is right that
makes a very strong prediction for the
shape of the light curve of that
supernova it should also be time dilated
guess what it is exactly as the
relativistic explanation would predict
there are many other reasons like that
and and um tests you can do you know
it's almost impossible to have photons
scatter off of matter without changing
their spectrum in some way and yet the
microwave background is a perfect black
body spectrum just like it was when it
left uh 14 billion years ago so
ned wright who's an astronomer at ucla
has a wonderful web page where he goes
through all the different possible
non-relativistic explanations of the
cosmological redshift and explains why
they don't work so yes we have thought
about it it doesn't work relativity is
the right answer
sam buck says more of a personal
question here how do you balance being
an extremely smart person with also
being kind and generous
there seem to be many people like you
who get into schools like harvard and
get jobs at places like caltech who
after having the world confirm their
brilliance seem to lose the ability to
interact with people they view as less
intellectually powerful how do you think
you avoided that pitfall and do you have
any advice for people whose academic
careers are going really well and worry
about falling into this trap
so i almost didn't include this question
because you know i don't i don't want to
talk too much about my brilliance and
kindness and generosity but then i
figured you know if i can't talk about
that or have someone else mention it on
my own patreon uh ama then where else is
it gonna be talked about you know
there's plenty of people on twitter
telling me i'm an idiot so i might as
well uh
be able to listen to people who are
telling me that i'm smart thank you for
saying that sam even though i think
you're exaggerating a little bit but
that's okay we'll let you get away with
it this time um there is a chicken and
egg question here um
i mean there are several chicken egg
questions here so one question is
is there some truth to the idea
that
brilliant people who are academically
super duper successful are less kind and
generous um i would i would dispute that
idea i think that there are
very obvious examples of people who are
brilliant and academically successful
who are not kind and generous but there
are also plenty of examples of people
who are i think it's very it would be
very very difficult to quantify that uh
and very very difficult to really show
that people who had reached these
um levels of achievement were somehow
systematically different than other
people in the distribution of their
kindness and generosity so there might
be a selection effect here that you
notice
people who are talking down to you and
you know just like it's easier to notice
negative book reviews than it is
positive ones if you're a book author so
maybe maybe not i'm just saying i
wouldn't necessarily take that as given
um the other chicken and egg problem is
does it come that you know you start
life as a
kind and generous person but then the
academic grind wears you down and by the
time you've reached success you are no
longer kind and generous or is for those
people who aren't kind and generous when
they get to success uh were they just
never like that all along right i mean
is there a causal impact or is it just a
filter that comes and i think the
filtering explanation works much better
than the cause and effect relationship i
would be my guess so if you're worried
as you say about you worry about falling
into this trap
i suspect the people who are kind and
generous when they're young remain
mostly that way if anything
academic success should allow you to be
more kind and generous right it's not
easier to be generous when you're
successful
than when you're struggling right it's
not easier to be self-deprecating when
everyone thinks you're a genius than
when everyone thinks you're an idiot
right and everyone thinks you're an
idiot and you're self-deprecating
it can just be thought of as being
accurate which is a little bit scary on
the other hand you know what i do want
to say substantively is
academia does not
select on kindness or generosity you
know when universities hire people to be
on their faculty
they do not say oh we want people who
are kind and generous that's just not
what they're looking for especially at
the highest uh level research
institutions which i guess we're
thinking about here where the brilliant
people want to congregate right um they
select on brilliance you know if you're
if you're up for a faculty job at
caltech they care about your research
accomplishments and your potential
future brilliance they they almost don't
care at all
about what good you are as a person i
mean it's really almost kind of
remarkable i hate to
air dirty laundry out there but the
extent to which
hiring committees could not possibly
care less about your personal qualities
as long as you're good at doing research
would be astonishing i think to people
in other sectors of the world i mean
maybe you know there's other sort of
high pressure
um high demand occupations like i don't
know wall street trader or
silicon valley or something like that
where they can really home in on ability
to do a job at any expense of
how good a person you are but academia
is one of those right i mean i i
explicitly remember you know different
people being considered for jobs at
different places i'm going to be as
vague as possible here because i don't
want to
pick on anybody but you know
a person was being considered and
someone else said well you know that
person's kind of a jerk
and over like as soon as they said it
everyone's like who cares what is their
research i want to know how good their
papers are that's what they care about
so i think it's less
that people are ground down by academia
or by
the journey to being a big shot
professor at a big shot institution
away from being kind and generous to
the people who are hired and promoted
etc it just doesn't matter whether
they're kind and generous or not maybe
they are that's fine but we don't we're
not looking for that that's a bonus that
comes along and honestly to be super
duper open about it teaching is the same
way you know you can be a good teacher
and also a jerk and you can be a bad
teacher and also a good person but the
point is that your ability to teach
students it does not affect how you're
going to get hired at one of these at
like harvard princeton caltech kind of
places they just don't care at all
and when they say they are the teaching
is very important to them they're just
lying it's just false uh what they mean
is they will occasionally tell their
existing professors to be better
teachers but they will never hire people
because they're good teachers that's
just not what they're about that's okay
there are other places that do hire
people because they're good teachers i
wrote a whole blog post you can look up
called the purpose of harvard is not to
educate people that's not a slam on
harvard the purpose of harvard
and you know the high level purpose like
forget about you're trying to say it's
just a you know a finishing school for
the elites or whatever but the
non-cynical purpose of harvard is to do
good research to do good academic
scholarship and to produce great things
that's the purpose
students are there to sort of allow that
purpose to happen but the teaching of
students is just an afterthought and
that's not even a cynical take that's
just what a place like harvard is about
there are other universities other
colleges and so forth where teaching
students is the point
but if harvard switched to caring mostly
about teaching students it wouldn't be
harvard anymore maybe that's good or
maybe it's bad but it would just be
different
peter benham says laughter is awesome
but really weird if you think about it
thoughts
uh no i do not have any really good
thoughts about this one um
is it really weird i mean that the
statement that laughter is weird implies
some sort of pre-existing standard
against which we measure whether things
are weird or not laughter is very
natural from some standards anyway from
some points of view but i bring up the
question not because i have anything
wise to say about it but because the
general it's a spandrel question i think
in general right spandrels being this
idea of uh steven j gould and niles
eldridge and thinking about evolution
that many things that happen according
to biological evolution are not
necessarily adaptive are not necessarily
they happen because this particular
feature gives us some reproductive
advantage evolutionarily speaking it
might be that some other feature gives
us a reproductive advantage and it comes
along with this particular feature or it
could just be that the genes that give
us some rep
some reproductive advantage also have
this particular effect so i don't know
whether laughter has some reason for
existing or whether or not it is the way
it is just because of other
physiological things that adapted for
good reasons and therefore we're stuck
with laughter but i do hear it is the
best medicine for what it's worth
jacob youngsma says is there a way to
search for previous questions and
answers uh mostly yes you know as i
mentioned there is a
website
preposterousuniverse.compodcast where
you can search all of the previous
episodes and their transcripts now for a
while we were doing amas that were
strictly on patreon
they were not
transcripts were not obtained for them
so those are not available but
in recent months for a while now anyway
we've been putting them on the regular
website with full transcripts and
everything so you can search there
vince corvo says i'm amazed at your
continued patience but here goes
is dewitt's many worlds moniker
preferred over ever its original term
relative state simply because it's more
provocative akin to big bang and black
hole but even more so it would seem that
a lot of the hysterical outcry from
casual critics could be diffused if the
name weren't so scary to little minds
um
i don't know about that you know i have
no problem with the name many worlds and
i don't know whether everett had any
problem with it it was not his coinage
his original original
uh name for the theory was simply the
theory of the universal wave function
which might be the best of them all i
don't like the relative state name
because it conveys no information right
away like if you don't know what is
already being talked about being told
it's a relative state theory of quantum
mechanics doesn't say very much and many
worlds is okay it is a theory of many
worlds it's not
what i always try to emphasize is it
doesn't posit many worlds all it posits
is that the schrodinger equation and the
wave function are to be taken both
seriously and literally
and then you get the many worlds coming
out so in that sense many worlds is not
the best name
you know in something deeply hidden i
originally called it austere quantum
mechanics because it's nothing but the
wave function in the schrodinger
equation but that was just a semi joke
because i was never really planning on
advocating that we start calling it that
it's just a way of getting into it in
the first place i i don't worry so much
about the labels honestly i wouldn't
fret about them just try to explain
things clearly would be my advice
luke says tim maldon writes the
following about einstein and god does
not play dice
it has been repeated ad nauseum that
einstein's main objection to quantum
theory was its lack of determinism
einstein could not abide a god who plays
dice but what annoyed einstein was not
the lack of determinism it was the
apparent failure of locality in the
theory on account of entanglement
i'd be interested in your take on it and
your sense of what the various schools
of thought specialties in physics think
about it if they do at all well
um i don't think that different schools
of thought especially i'm not exactly
sure what you mean by that last part of
the sentence different schools of
thought or specialties in physics don't
have individually
valuable or
precious takes on what einstein thought
right i mean they might have takes that
they care about on physics
um but i agree with tim i think he makes
a very uh compelling case that really
what einstein cared about was locality
um i mean look einstein was a very
quotable guy he said a lot of things
in conversation in letters uh that were
not meant for publication in talking to
journalists and so forth that you know
you can find contradictions of that he
says elsewhere you have to keep in mind
he might have just been kidding he might
have just been joshing around or not
being wanting to be taken very seriously
einstein did not go around repeating god
does not play dice this is crucially
important it was it was kind of a joke
that he said once whereas he really was
interested in locality that was the
whole point of the epr paper that
you could not find a locally realist
theory he cared about uh realism more
than anything else locality second most
i would say part of me says who cares
what einstein thought about but yeah
that's okay as a matter of history of
physics it does
matter
now tim also goes on to say that john
bell proved given the experimental data
that physics is non-local that quantum
mechanics is non-local i think that's
not quite true because there's some kind
of careful parsing you have to do in the
case of many worlds one of the
assumptions of bell's inequality is that
observational measurements have unique
outcomes
and in everett that's just not true
right because in different branches of
the wave function different outcomes are
obtained so strictly speaking bell's
theorem just doesn't say anything about
everettian quantum mechanics um so but
is ever writing quantum mechanics local
i think it's a tricky question because i
as i mentioned already this podcast i
think that there's such a thing as
gravity and i think there is a reason to
think that gravity has non-locality in
it so
my particular point of view on this
question is is very different than the
the mainstream of physics i think the
puzzle is why there is locality at all
not the puzzle of why there's
non-locality at all or how we can deal
with non-locality and accept it
non-locality is perfectly natural
generic hamiltonians are non-local
gravitational effects especially when
you combine them with quantum mechanics
naturally give you non-locality etc the
real question is why the universe looks
even a little bit local that's what i
would like to focus on
liam mccarty says on the philosophical
foundations of hypotheticals you often
reason with arguments like if we were
laplace's demon then but as you've said
many times it's impossible to be
laplace's demon even in principle so it
seems that any then that follows from if
must be moot and in general it must be
invalid to reason based on impossible
hypotheticals do you agree
no i don't agree because you know you
have to take the spirit you have to take
a statement like that in the spirit in
which it is offered so for example i'm
talking about relativity and i say
here's how you calculate the length of a
time-like trajectory and then i say you
can't move on space like trajectories
but if i draw one here is the length of
it right there's nothing wrong with that
there's absolutely nothing that is
contrary to logic or scientific practice
about doing that even though we cannot
actually travel on space like
trajectories um likewise you can make
statements uh you make all sorts of
counterfactual statements that are
impossible in the real world um so when
you say something like if we were
laplace's demon then that's just a
formulation that is supposed to try to
help us understand determinism that's
all it is it's just a vivid
metaphor for trying to appreciate the
implications of this idea that there is
a certain set of data
information that is specified at one
moment of time that suffices to fix what
will happen at other moments of time
it's just a colorful way of saying that
nothing wrong with that
paul meigs says not your particular area
of expertise but i know my 38 year old
son asked me after reading a really
interesting piece on
fusion
in the new yorker dad do you think we
will harness nuclear fusion in my
lifetime i answered if by harness you
mean useful i said no do you think i was
overly dismal or realistic
so
there's a little bit i have to say about
this almost nothing directly answering
your questions i have to say about it so
i don't know
whether we will harness nuclear fusion
in your lifetime my lifetime etc that's
an engineering problem you know the
fundamental physics says there is energy
to be released in converting hydrogen to
heavier elements okay that much we're
sure about but the whole question of
whether or not we can make it practical
and get more energy out than we put in
is an engineering question on which i am
entirely unqualified to talk
the one non-trivial thing i will say is
um
it's certainly been true that we've been
promised
nuclear fusion as a power source for a
long time and it hasn't come true so the
question is
what do we do with that information how
do we update our credences given that
we've previously been promised that this
is going to happen and it doesn't
and i would
i would sort of stake out a middle
position here you know there are some
people who would say
look we were wrong before but this time
we're right
so if we say that nuclear fusion will be
giving us uh
um
power more power out than we put in
within 10 years or within 50 years
whatever it is we should believe it and
i think that's a credible thing to be
imagined saying if you have a reason for
it you can't just say well but this time
we're right because i have trust that
the people who are saying it know what
they're talking about
it would be much more convincing if you
could actually understand why they were
wrong the first time and why those
reasons do not apply this time right on
the other hand
i do not i'm not going to agree with
people who say well we're always
promised this once ever you know 20
years in the future even no matter what
date it is therefore it will never
happen
that's not true either you know some
things
there's a joke within nasa that there's
a uniform universal form of the function
of
days until launch versus time
you would think that that's a straight
line right days until launch goes down
over time one day per day but in fact
launches are always delayed so the curve
sort of goes down linearly for a while
then it goes up and then it zigzags up
and down because you know it bounces up
and you go up we're delayed and then it
goes down once a day up again etc but
eventually the launch has happened right
and eventually we might very well get uh
sustained nuclear fusion with more power
out i just don't know so
i don't think the fact we don't have it
yet as evidence we won't
and i don't think that optimism is
evidence that we will unless that
optimism is based on a clear explicit
understanding of why we were wrong
in the past
frank layman says would you consider
yourself a stargazer did the night sky
fascinate you as a child um yeah not
that much i mean a little bit you know i
always loved physics really i really
love fundamental physics and you know
that included not only particle physics
and gravity but also cosmology and
astrophysics and things like that and
my family which was resolutely
non-academic non-scholarly
uh had no idea what particles were but
they knew what astronomy was so they
gave me all sorts of books about you
know planets and stars so i read that
stuff and i thought it was cool space
travel science fiction etc but it was
never my passion i always want to know
the underlying laws of stuff
i was an undergraduate astronomy major
and part of my
part-time job was doing planetary not
planetarium shows so much um observatory
shows taking people to the observatory
and showing them
a couple nebulae couple planets couple
binary stars stuff like that so there's
a brief moment in my life when i could
find some interesting things in the sky
with a telescope but that moment is long
gone
dlp says a personal advice question i'm
planning to move to a new city to be
closer to my romantic partner
my partner is wonderful and things are
going very well with them but i would
like to establish a social circle in the
new city that's not connected to them do
you have any advice for making new
friends in one's thirties outside of a
shared work or academic context
so uh
short answer no i don't really have any
great advice i don't think that
this is a something that is subjectible
to an algorithm you know what i mean in
other words i don't think that there is
sort of a strategy that you consciously
adopt to make new friends you can
certainly try harder or try less and
that's the one reason i wanted to answer
the question just because the
non-trivial thing i can say is if
you know
depending on your personality is like it
is certainly possible
to just either stay home or go to work
and don't live that's those are the only
elements of your life right and then
you're not going to make other friends
uh unconnected from people at home and
at work for obvious reasons so much like
for romantic advice which i know is not
what you're looking for but the same
principle applies
that you do have to put yourself out
there a little bit and even though the
stakes are much higher for romantic
connections than for mere friendships
the same kinds of jeopardy apply in the
sense that you can embarrass yourself
you can look bad you can say awkward
things that you regret later i mean
maybe the chances are lower if you're
just trying to small talk with potential
friends but they're still out there so i
get
that again depending on who you are if
you're very gregarious extroverted
person this is not a consideration but
for some people just going to a party
where you don't know many people
is hard is fraught with peril and and i
get that
but after you asked your question you i
thought about
the friends circles that i have uh with
my wife jennifer in los angeles and you
know it's a very heterogeneous
collection of ways in which we met them
um you know i had some friends just from
work uh when jennifer moved in she had
almost no friends directly in la and
since then she's made plenty of friends
who like she's closer with than i am etc
many friends we actually first got to
know online in one way or another either
you know on social media or uh by i
don't know emailing or being connected
with other friends things like that
and another people we just met at random
events really that's why that's why i'm
skeptical of the algorithmic approach
you know one of our very best friends
we met because
uh we had another friend who had been
connected to us by a third friend and
this person was leaving town and having
a party so we went to their goodbye
party
and once we arrived at the party this
woman comes up to us and says
everyone here is accompanied by small
children it looks like you are not
please talk to me
and we bonded over that and you know
many times that will happen and then
you'll never see them again in this case
you became very good friends so i think
it's unpredictable i think that you know
that you need to go through a lot of
people before you find ones you really
connect with and uh go through a lot of
people who you are not gonna end up
being friends with and keep trying keep
putting yourself out there that's the
only tangible advice i have
napoleon's corporal
asks a priority question
the simulation hypothesis has come up in
several episodes and i believe that one
of the reasons it has come into vogue is
the relatively recent finding that much
of the reality that we experience that
we used to think of as continuous and
flowing seems to actually be discrete
and granular
light time and even space itself our
evidence strongly suggests this way
the idea that reality is a consciousness
driven digital construction rather than
a simulation has its followers and some
very persuasive arguments to support it
given that there undeniably is something
rather than nothing it is the simplest
explanation the initial big bang theory
was seductively simple and intuitive but
when cosmic inflation and quantum theory
reared their ugly heads that simplicity
went right into the dustbin is it really
likely that the something that has
always been is so incredibly arbitrary
and contrived yet i rarely see this
concept openly discussed and seriously
considered my question is why are
serious scientists so reluctant to
consider this perspective
so
unfortunately even though there's a
priority question i think that you
phrased it a little bit badly because
it's a long question and then by the end
you say i rarely see this concept openly
discussed why are scientists reluctant
to just consider this perspective but
i'm not entirely sure what you're
referring to by this construction this
concept this perspective i think you're
referring to
the idea that reality is a consciousness
driven digital construction rather than
a simulation so there's separate
responses here depending on whether
you're asking why don't we take the
simulation argument seriously versus why
don't we take the construction uh
consciousness driven digital
construction seriously so first i think
that it's i don't know exactly what you
mean but i would completely disagree
with the idea that we have recently
discovered that reality is uh uh
discrete and granular granular or
pixelated um i don't know what you're
talking about there
the best
understanding we have of the fundamental
nature of reality is as a quantum field
theory which is resolutely non-discrete
it's completely continuous quantum
mechanics in general is is continuous
there are observables that are discrete
but that is exactly
the observability of them that is
discrete not the underlying reality so
i'm not quite sure what you're referring
to about the evidence strongly
suggesting uh that light space time are
somehow pixelated
um
second on the simulation argument again
um
i think a lot of physicists don't pay
attention to that just because it's not
answering a question that we are
have as a pressing issue right um i mean
i think a lot of physicists would say
yeah maybe it's true maybe it's not i
have no way of knowing and it doesn't
help me understand the world that i see
so i'm not going to care that much
i think that's the the major reason out
there without advocating or sorry
without adjudicating that right here i
would say that's what is in the back of
the minds of most scientists
so you're specifically but i think what
you're asking about is the specific idea
that reality is a consciousness driven
digital construction rather than a
simulation
so again i would i'm sorry i have to
like disagree with everything that your
uh uh all the assumptions behind this
theory for one thing quantum theory is
not uh arbitrary and contrived at all
quantum theory is incredibly simple the
problem as i see it is that it is too
simple the idea if you really believe in
an everetti inversion where all you have
is a wave function and the schrodinger
equation um
all of the effort goes into teasing out
the implications of that simple idea but
the underlying idea is literally almost
as simple as as it is possible to
imagine an idea being while having a
chance of understanding our world so to
say that it is incredibly arbitrary uh
seems way off base
likewise for cosmic inflation which is a
completely different um
kind of theory than quantum theory is
it simplifies things uh you know we had
a bunch of facts about the universe the
original motivation for inflation was
the universe was spatially flat
uh it was uh very homogeneous on very
large scales then there became there was
also the thing there were no monopoles
and it became the issue of the origin of
structure and all of these disparate
things were explained by this one simple
idea of inflation so to say that again
that it's arbitrary and contrived
doesn't seem accurate but also we don't
know whether inflation is true so it's
very different than quantum theory in
that sense
finally
um
i don't know much about what you mean by
the idea of a consciousness driven
digital construction
but as soon as you use the word
consciousness
that's when i'm going to say now we're
talking about something that is
incredibly complicated incredibly ill
understood right i mean it's obvious
that consciousness is not very well
understood it is much less well-defined
than relativity or cosmology or quantum
mechanics or anything like that
so i mean it's a conceivable hypothesis
that you're willing that you're welcome
to consider and think about but the idea
that right off the bat saying that
reality is a consciousness driven
digital construction is somehow
simpler
just seems completely wrong to me
completely backwards
i think that it might give the
appearance of simplicity by the by
virtue of being ill-defined
because it's only vaguely specified what
you mean by consciousness you can say
well this explains all the things i want
to explain
but a good scientific theory
is not just stated in a small number of
words but is unbendingly precise
right a good scientific theory says
this thing is an element of this
mathematical space which evolves
according to this equation right it
doesn't just say consciousness or even
it doesn't even just say physics or
stuff or material right there's a very
clear mathematical structure that is
making predictions that's what we mean
by a theory that is uh simple and and
compelling it doesn't mean it's true but
the theories have been very successful
always have that form so far
brad malt says in the september ama you
answered a question about whether there
is a branch of the wave function where
the germans won world war ii you said
yes but we should take comfort in the
knowledge that is a very thin branch
which i understand to mean the
probability of anyone ending up on that
branch is small
but does thin have any meaning after the
world has branched uh in suppose that
there are two possible outcomes in
superposition one with ten percent
probability one with ninety percent
probability
once decoherence occurs there are just
two branches and i'm on one of them
hasn't the meaning of thin and thick
gone away uh yes
absolutely 100 once you're inside a
branch the thickness of the branch is
completely unobservable to you the idea
of thickness and thinness is only
relevant
sorry i'm in bespoke thickness and
thinness
is only relevant when we're comparing
different branches from some kind of
god's eye view but that's exactly what
we're doing when we're talking about a
branch where the nazis won world war ii
right i mean we're not in that branch to
the people who are in that branch
that's their that's their reality that's
absolutely real the fact that it's a
thin branch doesn't matter but if we're
comparing all sorts of branches to each
other that's when the thickness or
thinness matters a lot
josh says it makes sense to me that gr
predicts divergences from newtonian
gravity such as gravitational lensing
what i don't understand is why it
predicts divergences when it comes to
the motions of bodies such as the
anomaly in mercury's orbit can you
explain why gr newton and gravity
predict different behavior in this case
um so i
i did not do what i should have done
here or what i would have done if if
this were a different situation and you
know gone back to my gr book and re-gone
through the derivation of the procession
of the perihelion and mercury um there's
a i remember the what you do there's an
effective potential you define there is
a new term in that effective potential
that goes as one over r cubed instead of
one over r squared which is the inverse
square law for newton um so there's a
technical answer but that's probably not
what you're looking for
um so there is definitely a sort of hand
wavy answer to why there are differences
at all between newtonian gravity and
general relativity in newtonian gravity
there's a very simple geometric reason
why the force of gravity is one over r
squared namely
you can think about lines of
gravitational force
extending out
from the gravitating body like the sun
or whatever it is and these lines never
end they don't have they so i should say
they only end on gravitating bodies they
do not
dilute away or disappear in empty space
okay they only end on matter on a source
for gravity
so if you have just one spherical body
and empty space around it there's going
to be lines of force radiating away from
it and those lines are going to dilute
away in a number density as the area of
a sphere that you draw around that body
goes up and guess what the area goes up
as r squared as the distance of the
sphere the radius of the sphere squared
that's where you get an inverse square
law in newtonian gravity in general
relativity that's almost true but
there's a new effect that comes in
which is that
there's a field theory in general
relativity a propagating field
and that field interacts with itself
if you want to think about it in the
language of particles which you don't
need to do it's just classical
relativity but if you want to think
about it in the language of particles
it's as if gravitons in general
relativity interact with each other
because gravitons themselves have energy
and gravity couples to everything with
energy even to other gravitons
whereas in newtonian gravity there's no
gravitons at all but gravity does not
interact with itself the gravitational
field in newtonian gravity is not a
source of gravity
whereas the gravitational field in
general relativity is so when the
gravitational field becomes relatively
strong in general relativity we expect
it to deviate from the newtonian
prediction because there's an extra
source of gravity the gravitational
field itself and mercury of course is
not only relatively elliptical compared
to other planets it's the closest to the
sun it's feeling the strongest
gravitational field so that is where you
would first expect the deviations uh
from perfect linearity to show up
now having said all of that let me let
me footnote that by saying
everything i just said is true about
general relativity versus newtonian
gravity uh i am not sure that is the
most accurate explanation exactly of the
procession of mercury um so that's a
slightly different question it's a it's
a related question but there could be
like a simpler more geometric way of
talking about the procession of mercury
that i'm just not aware of right now so
i'm not giving it to you but what i said
about the difference between gr and
newton is definitely right
rob butler says
i've often read that black holes will
eventually dominate the entire landscape
of the universe until they too evaporate
in your episode with priya natarajan she
described the formation of supermassive
black holes as predominantly events of
the early universe and also that
although massive they are a small
fraction of a galaxy's total mass
given galaxy mergers ejections of stars
from their host galaxies uh all that
stuff is it possible that the aging
universe might comprise many wandering
objects instead of it's often described
destiny as a sleepy neighborhood of
postprandial black holes
well um
i'm i'm not a super expert here uh it is
completely possible in fact i think it's
almost certainly true that it's not
going to be everything in the universe
that converts to black holes
there are for instance in our galaxy our
galaxy has a lot of stars in it forget
about the dark matter for a little while
but uh imagine the galaxy is a
collection of stars
stars interact with each other
gravitationally occasionally
there are close encounters between two
stars moving along different
trajectories and as we discussed earlier
in the ama
there can be a slingshot effect
momentum from one star can be borrowed
by the other star and it can be ejected
from the galaxy this is a general
feature of just newtonian gravity that
uh mutually gravitating collections of
particles will spit out occasional
particles that just become unbound and
go away forever so that's going to
happen so there'll be wandering stars or
planets or rocks or whatever in the
universe
but i think that most
stuff in the universe will be uh will
stay connected to a galaxy and the trick
is you have to wait a long time right
you're talking about very very long time
scales here so it is true that in our
milky way galaxy for example today the
supermassive black hole at the center is
a tiny fraction you know 0.1 percent or
whatever it is of the total mass of the
probably much smaller than 0.1 of the
total mass of the galaxy
but
just wait things fall into the black
hole and they don't come out right so
the point is if you just wait a very
very long time
uh eventually all that stuff is going to
fall into the black hole and the
question is
which happens first does all the stuff
fall into the black hole or does the
black hole evaporate away and i think
that uh you know within some reasonable
set of parameters most of the stuff
inside a galaxy will fall into the black
hole before the black hole evaporates
away that's why we think that there will
be a long period of the universe's
history in the future where it will be
just sleepy postprandial black holes
carlos nunez says
today a very dear family member died
have you ever had anyone close to you
die and if so how have you dealt with
the loss so i'm very sorry uh to hear
that carlos i know it can be very hard
uh
yes you know i've had uh people close to
me die and members of the family and
things like that once you reach a
certain age it's almost inevitable
and it's never easy right it's a hard
thing even as as convinced as we can be
that it's going to happen when it
actually happens uh it's tough and it's
tough in part because you know both
because we remember
having them with us and because it's
it's inevitable to imagine alternative
futures where they're still around right
and and that's better those futures are
better and so we're in one of the bad
futures
um i don't have any really strong again
techniques or algorithms or whatever to
dealing
with this kind of loss
one thing is it will absolutely take
time
there's no shortcut that i know from
experience personal and with other
friends and the closer the person is who
dies the longer it will take and there's
no rushing it i mean there's things you
can do that you know uh make yourself
more healthy and and uh dealing with it
etc but you can't just
shortcut the process you know the
process of grief
is of adjusting to a new reality and
that just takes time and uh there's a
continuous you know you're still living
your life
there are things that are happening to
you in your life and that you need to
think about etc and eventually you will
almost always come to an equilibrium
where you accept that this person is no
longer around and you're living a
different kind of life and you're still
sad that they're gone but that sadness
is not front and center in your
consciousness uh but
in the immediate aftermath of the event
it might very well be
front and center and there's nothing
wrong with that it's completely okay to
um grieve and to be sad about it you
know it's not like your sadness is
somehow a mistake or a failure um let me
say one thing which i don't know whether
it's relevant or helpful or or anything
but it was very striking to me
at least once
someone close passed away
and members there were members of the
family and an inner circle who were very
religious
and they were members who were not
and the people who were not religious
uniformly handled it much better
and i don't think that's necessarily
generalizable i think it might depend on
those particular people in the
particular way they were religious etc
but it spoke to the fact that
acceptance matters
and in some sense uh the religious
people really genuinely believe that the
the person would die and go to heaven
and the non-religious people thought
that was the end of their existence um
but somehow it was more acceptable to
believe it was the end of their
existence it wasn't hanging on right it
was a uh
leaping into the new reality where the
person no longer existed and that was
easier than the sort of halfway house
where you think well a version of them
still exists but i don't have access to
that person or whatever
again i have no data on whether or not
that's generalizable
um whether or not it's just these
individual people
et cetera et cetera but
maybe it suggests that part of the
process of
acceptance and dealing with it is
real acceptance right you know really
accepting that whether you're religious
or not
for you they are gone um it's not an
easy thing to think but i mean maybe the
non-religious perspective
anticipates it more fully right like you
have a finite lifespan we have three
billion heartbeats on average that's how
much we're all gonna get um with a big
error bar there and that makes the
moments you have here on earth all the
more precious in my view
again nothing wrong with grieving no way
to hurry it up that i know of uh but it
does you do deal with it there's a it's
a
just like we talked about with the
species and ecology before
life is flux life is changing
life is uh
undergone in a set of different
conditions from moment to moment and the
trick of life is not to find the perfect
conditions and stay there forever the
trick of life is to adapt and adjust to
the conditions that you're in while also
trying to improve them it's a balance
that you have to keep up forever for as
long as you live i should say because
you don't live forever
nicholas wyberg says how can we
distinguish between black holes and
other massive objects such as neutron
stars by observations apologies for the
whiplash of going between very very
different questions uh from topic to
topic here but that's the nature of an
ama sorry about that anyway how can we
distinguish between black holes and
other massive objects such as neutron
stars by observation perhaps our best
theories predict the dense objects
beyond a certain mass must be black
holes
but what if the theories are wrong for
instance could the object in the center
of our galaxy actually be a massive
neutron star
yeah it's always possible our theories
are wrong and
i think that it's not a yes no question
i think that there are different ways
our theories can be wrong that are more
or less plausible so you know again
astronomers have absolutely wondered
about this how do we know if it's a
black hole and um
as you say there's a theoretical
prediction if something is a certain
mass and a certain size that it has to
be a black hole but maybe the theory is
wrong
what you can do uh so there's there's
two steps one thing that people try to
do is just to say it's again what i sort
of implicitly uh included already you
simultaneously measure not just the mass
of the thing but the size of it right um
and at some point if general relativity
is roughly right
then um if the size of the thing is
smaller or as small as its short shield
radius there's literally nothing else it
can be other than a black hole if
general relativity is roughly right so
that has nothing to do with our theories
of matter or pressure or equations of
state or any of that stuff that go into
neutron stars etc it's a pure general
relativity question
but of course general relativity can
also be wrong so the slightly more
sophisticated thing that people try to
do which is also
harder to do
is to think about the emission of light
from different objects so typically
objects or not typically but often
these objects will have accretion disks
around them these equations are
radiating
um
and they have a small object at the
center nominally a black hole and so
what you can try to do is to say there's
so much radiation coming from the
secretion disk that the thing that is in
the middle would glow
if it were not a black hole right you're
heating it up
um and you can try to sort of put limits
on the size of the thing versus its
luminosity and and stuff like that all
that is a lot more hand wavy a lot more
to do accurately but we try
um at that 100 confidence level you'll
never be sure unless you can go up and
look at the thing so um but honestly you
know having said all that that's all
very very careful and very precise and
and uh
correct but
they're black holes trust me about that
you know there there's not a lot of i
mean there are some edge cases where the
evidence isn't that good that they're
black holes and maybe there's something
interesting but for something like the
center of our galaxy
there's not a lot of plausible
alternatives other than a black hole
sheamus mclennan says given unlimited
resources is there an experiment you
would like to conduct or have others
conduct in any branch of science
this could include the theoretically
possible even if not currently
technologically possible
um it's a good question but i don't have
a great answer to it in the sense that
as i was thinking about it um
here's the problem uh the thing about
experiments especially interesting ones
is you don't know what answer you're
gonna get ahead of time so i have things
i would like to know
but i don't necessarily have experiments
that will clearly give me the answer to
them right i would like to know what you
know why the higgs boson mass is so much
lower than the planck scale you know the
hierarchy problem of particle physics we
were hopeful that the lhc would tell us
that that we would find some particles
with similar masses to the higgs boson
that would help us work out why its mass
was so low but we haven't yet maybe we
will the next round of the lhc but we
haven't yet
you could i mean the obvious thing to
say is let's build a particle collider
um
with uh planck scale energies or
superplank scale energies and then make
it a sufficiently precise one that we
can really just find every single
particle that exists below the planck
scale that's probably the answer i would
give um
but we have to be open to the fact that
even that wouldn't give us the answer to
this question that we're asking you know
i'd like to know what the dark matter is
but there's one kind of experiment that
would find the dark matter if it's a
weakly interacting particle there's a
whole other kind of experiment that
would find it if it's an axion or
something like that so it's very hard uh
even if we had unlimited resources it's
hard to say what is the one experiment
that would really help us out that's why
we have to do all of them
jeff b says
do you think that finding a subject to
be a chore to learn is a sign that we
should spend our time doing something
else
you said it very well there are things
that it would be fun to have already
learned but the process in getting there
seems much less appealing should we only
spend our time doing things that we find
enjoyable or is it worth it to sometimes
grind to get a new level of
understanding so
a hundred percent um we have to
sometimes grind we have to sometimes do
chores you know look when you're
learning general relativity it's one of
the most interesting subjects in the
world but there are all these greek
indices all over the place and these
covariant derivatives with a lot of
tensors flying around and there is no
way to get around
tedious manipulation of them before it
becomes second nature if you want to
play basketball you gotta shoot a lot of
free throws you gotta practice uh if you
wanna play the piano you gotta do scales
right all of this stuff you wanna learn
new language you have to memorize
vocabulary and practice your grammar um
of course that's just always a part of
the process there is no royal road to
geometry as euclid is purported to have
said um so yeah i hope i did not give
any other impression there's a bigger
picture question you know if you find an
entire field to be mostly chore
then should you switch to another field
where it seems like a lot more fun you
know that that's a more difficult subtle
question but within any one field
i mean i think that most of the activity
that is necessary to learn that field in
the first place and maybe even
most of the activity to produce
something useful within that field will
be by itself a chore that is part of a
bigger
achievement that you get along the way
johnny says i've heard the term fiber
bundle used a lot is it possible to
explain what that is with mere language
or is it one of those things that
require math to make sense of so i don't
know where you're hanging out uh johnny
where you hear the term fiber bundle
used a lot it is very common in both
mathematics and physics you know when we
talked before about gauge theories fiber
bundles is the setting uh where gage
theories is uh that was not great
grammar um gauge theories are set in the
context of what are called fiber bundles
it's actually not that difficult um
think of it this way when you have
quarks in the strong interactions you
might have been told that quarks are
either red green or blue there are three
colors of quarks
that's not exactly true i mean of course
it's not exactly true
but it's not only not exactly true
because they're not really the colors
but also because it's not just there are
three kinds of quarks there's a
three-dimensional space of quarks a
three-dimensional vector space so just
like real space where it's up down left
right forward backward three dimensions
there is a vector space where the quarks
live and that vector space is
three-dimensional so it's not that
quarks are either red green or blue
they are some combination they are a
vector in red green blue space okay
every quark is like that
and the point is that the
uh the gauge symmetry is simply the
symmetry that it doesn't matter how you
orient your axes i i've called it
coordinate variants before but it's the
same idea you can orient the axes you
call red green and blue however you want
that is literally the symmetry
underlying the strong interactions
and the fiber bundle comes in because
when you think about these quarks these
quarks are fields right there's a quark
field
up quark field down quark field
anti-quark fields et cetera so at every
point in space
there's a quark field and this quark
field takes the form of a little vector
in this three-dimensional color space
that's what a fiber bundle is a fiber
bundle is just some vector space or it
doesn't need to be a vector space but
some kind of mathematical space
one of which is attached to every point
in space-time or more generally to some
underlying manifold that you would might
care about so you can have things like
circle bundles so instead of a vector
space you have a circle at every point
in space
in fact the
there's some clever way that you can
think of the three-dimensional sphere
as a one-dimensional fiber over a
two-dimensional sphere i know that none
of those words are meaningful in any way
but the point is that there are examples
that are not vector spaces
fiber bundles are just generalizations
of the idea that you can have vectors at
every point in space that's all it is
different kinds of vectors different
kinds of non-vectors at every point in
space and then you need to talk about
how the vectors or other things at
different points of space are related to
each other
and this requires the idea of what you
call a connection
on the fiber bundle which tells you how
to connect the values of fibers at
nearby points i talk about this a little
bit in the biggest ideas in the universe
in the gauge theory section or in the
symmetry section maybe but i don't call
them fiber bundles that just seem
superfluous language i hope that made
some sense that's as much you're going
to get from me right now
ken wolfe says when listening to your
conversation with kiara marletto on
constructor theory
the idea that this methodology could be
applied both to particle physics into
higher level emergent behavior reminded
me of the scale-free behavior you had
discussed with nigel golden feld in your
previous episode do you think there's
any possible link here or am i
conflating two completely different
ideas
um i think
they're not connected this is my guess
and i say that only very tentatively
because maybe i'm missing
something
when we were talking with nigel about
scale-free behavior we're talking about
a single kind of system
um which can be analyzed on different
scales right so when you have the izing
model right a bunch of little spins that
have some orientation either up or down
you can sort of chunk them up into
domains you can look at one spin or a
two by two array of spins or a three by
three array of spins or a four by four
array of spins and you can ask about
average properties in each of those
chunks and then you could ask how the
statistics of those properties change so
when i look at each individual spin how
many of them are up how many of them are
down when i look at two by two arrays
how many of them are all up how many of
them are all down how many of them are
in between et cetera
and the idea of scale-free behavior is
you get roughly the same behavior no
matter how big chunks you make so if you
have for example if you're at a very low
temperature
what that means is all the spins want to
line up so you do not get scale-free
behavior what you get is all the spins
are lined up so if you have all of the
spins they're doing things and that's
interesting but then if you have a block
of spins you learn nothing new because
they're all lined up once you know one
spin you know all the other ones whereas
if you have fluctuations
and so on the other end on the other
side of the
limit if you have super high temperature
then knowing one spin tells you nothing
about any of the other spins so there's
no structure in looking at larger and
larger chunks either it's in this in
between critical regime
where there's interesting information on
every scale
um so in other words the correlation
length at zero temperature is infinity
one spin is correlated with all the
other spins the carbon correlation
length at infinite temperature is zero
and in between there's some interesting
correlation length um so that's all
about a single system looked at in
different ways what kiara and i were
talking about is different kinds of
systems right
and also you know with what what she
wants to investigate is the idea of a
single methodology or perspective on how
we formulate laws of physics
that could be applicable to different
kinds of systems
it's not a statement that the behavior
of those systems is the same or even
related to each other at different
scales
it's just the way that we can think
about the laws of physics rather than
being a laplacian kind of picture where
you give me initial conditions and then
solve for equations instead you ask
about what things are possible and what
things are not possible
that framework that paradigm that
approach might be applicable to a wide
variety of different phenomena it's not
necessarily part of the picture that the
phenomena be physically related to each
other or have similar behavior at
different scales just the similar
language for behaving for describing
that behavior that's why i think that
they're not necessarily related it's a
different kind of comparison but again
maybe there's something lurking there
that i'm not really aware of
sekar rabala i guess sorry let me say
one more
slightly more definite thing there um to
ken's question there are absolutely
examples of emergent behavior
which are not scale-free right
skill-free behavior is somehow special
um you know a classic example of
emergent behavior which is not
scale-free is we've just been talking
about quarks and the strong interactions
uh above a certain energy
quarks are free quarks and gluons just
fly around all by themselves there is a
definite energy a definite scale the qcd
scale that separates that kind of
behavior from the kind of behavior we're
familiar with in the low energy world
where quarks are confined into protons
and neutrons or other kinds of hadrons
so there's not scale-free behavior there
is a definite scale on one side of which
things act one way and on the other side
of things things on the other side of
which things act the other way on one
side the natural language to use is one
of quarks and gluons on the other side
the natural language to use is one of
baryons and mesons okay so that's a very
common emergent kind of property the
scale-free behavior is a little bit
special
all right sakai rabala says
i have a process-related question for
you you cover a lot of interesting
topics with a variety of guests my
question is how do you decide which
topics and how do you decide which guest
to invite to the for the topics you want
to cover
um yeah i mean it's a combination of
both sometimes i pick a topic first and
then go for a guest other times a guest
just seems really really good so i go
grab them and it's a very haphazard
thing you know this is the
anti-algorithm ama episode there's no
algorithm for me finding the guests or
the topics it's stuff i'm interested in
you know i do want to keep things lively
uh intellectually so
i want to mix things up i want to have
you know if i don't want to have three
physicists in a row and i don't have
three economists in a row or three
uh novelists in a row right i want to
have a variety of things from week to
week i want to keep you all guessing
what's going to happen next
um and i think that's fun for me
i'm not interested in every single topic
out there there are some topics that i'm
just not that interested in and you know
i'm not that interested in
well look i get a lot of you know once
your podcast gets to a certain uh level
of recognizability you get a lot of
pitches i get a lot of emails from
people who would like to be on the
podcast mostly not from
the people themselves sometimes from
people themselves and again i've said
this before that's fine you're welcome
to suggest yourself as a guest on the
podcast as long as you are not insulted
if i say no right
maybe it's just not a good fit
but i get a lot of pitches from pr
agents or from you know media people at
publishing houses when people have books
coming out
and there are a lot of books on
self-help
and i don't mean like you know be
happier
it's more like i mean yeah be happier as
part of it you know be more successful
here's your algorithm for finding
success or for getting books written or
for uh improving your health or stuff
like that oh my goodness so many of
those i'm not that interested in those
that much it may be the case like it was
the case with lighty klotz recently for
example that there is some interesting
scholarly point about the universe
which can then be used to help you live
your life you know his point was
human beings have this uh prejudice this
bias when we look at designs for
improving them by adding things rather
than subtracting things okay and there's
sort of
neuroscience and psychology behind that
as well as engineering theory behind
that so that's intrinsically interesting
it may also suggest
ways that you could uh improve your own
going through life i hope that
occasionally podcast guests tell you
things uh that might help you get
through your life but that's never the
primary point for me the primary point
for me is are we illuminating some
aspect of how the universe works
and for those purposes i take the
universe in an extremely broad sense
so you're part of the universe
politics is part of the universe
religion is part of the universe music
and art are part of the universe etc but
it's it's that scholarly intellectual
let's figure out how stuff works that is
driving me and within that i'm looking
for a very wide variety of guests and
also you know young people old people
people from different fields all that
stuff diversity along many different
axes
edward morris says could you please
comment on the concept of imaginary time
i'm wondering if it's just a convenient
mathematical trick or it should be more
than that like a clue to some deeper
truth about the nature of time itself uh
nope it's just a convenient mathematical
trick as far as i know um i mean i i all
of my experience and i do have
experience i've written about it etc
it's just a trick and it's not even just
for general relativity i mean the the
origin of imaginary time actually comes
from what is called the wkb
approximation in quantum mechanics from
early explorations of quantum tunneling
it's just a trick there's lots of tricks
and then it takes on a little bit more
of a reality when you translate it into
words
uh don't fall for that just a trick
john morgan says you clearly have a ton
of experience debating complex topics in
a thoughtful way and i really
appreciated how that's allowed me to
reconnect with my physics education
through your podcasts i'm curious about
your strategies for handling topics with
more personal stakes and passion for
example debating a controversial
politician or the merits of obtaining a
covid vaccine with an intransigent
relative i have difficulty keeping my
cool which immediately creates my
ability to think coherently this doesn't
just have implications for personal
lives because for folks in a leadership
position we sometimes face hot button
issues which present challenges while
navigating the complexities of setting
an example maintaining an inclusive
environment etc
yeah so i completely
appreciate the issue that you're
bringing up it's a very important one
it's a universal one and it's a
difficult one
um
i think that the fact that you recognize
the issue is 98
of the pr of the solution to the issue
there's no easy solution look we all
have
emotions right we all have biases we all
have immediate visceral reactions to
things especially when we think people
are being dumb or when we think people
are being evil right i mean this gets
our hair rising up and it gets our blood
boiling or whatever metaphor you want to
use
that shows up whether it's in real life
or in social media or whatever and it's
it will always show up and
a lot of people don't want to deal with
it a lot of people like it right they're
people who seek it out they get that
they get kind of an endorphin rush from
arguing with people in a passionate
heated way
other people sort of
i would say kind of
effectively act that way
while remaining
for all appearances sake to be
level-headed like they remain
level-headed but they say things that
drive the conversation downward rather
than to a more elevated uh
plane so
send sometimes you want to give in yeah
the emotions are not entirely bad but i
take the point of your of your question
you know we would like to be the good
examples right we would like to
um be the examples of thinking things
true through carefully of listening to
other points of view
to being the voice of reason
and i don't always succeed at that you
know for goodness sake i certainly know
that i would aspire to do that but i
don't always succeed and i try so my
point is trying is most of the battle
try well it's not even most of the
battle but it is the single most
important thing that you have to put
into your
tech in your toolbox of strategies if
you are reflective if you are self-aware
and cognizant of what is going on you
will be able to say yourself you know
i wasn't quite as calm and rational that
time as i should have been
what can i do to be better next time and
i think that's you know i try to do that
i try to get better
plenty of examples things i've done and
said in the past where i was too quick
and too clip
made things worse rather than better
trying harder is is already puts you in
the top two percent of uh of
interlocutors in this particular
aspect um
other than that you know
i guess the other thing
is to recognize and correct for
our innate tribalism
right
we always it's a very natural human
thing to divide people into teams
our team and the other team and to
conceptualize things as a competition
and then once you do that once you've
slipped into that mode your goal is to
win the competition right not to reach
mutual understanding or you know uh
just discuss things and learn more et
cetera et cetera if somehow you can
recognize when that happens and correct
for it
if even with people you deeply deeply
disagree with
you can have an attitude of mutual
learning
then you'll you'll be fine and that's
it sounds hard to do
and it is even harder than it sounds
because some people
aren't going to be reasoned with
um they're just not i mean they are
either evil or dumb or whatever people
like that exist so it's not just you
should always accept the point of view
of everybody else some people's point of
views are not worth accepting
but probably a lot more people's are
worth listening to than we do in real
life we probably air mostly on the other
side
um so
in that case i'd you know i would just
disengage you know i try to organize my
life
so that i have to put up with people
like that as little as possible
i block a lot of people on twitter for
example you may have heard me mention
this and people are sometimes like wow
you know why did i get blocked aren't
you in favor of free speech and whatever
no i'm in favor of you being able to
tweet i'm not in favor of me having to
listen to you no matter how annoying you
are if you're annoying even a little bit
annoying why should i listen to you why
should i have you on my twitter timeline
i don't want that it's not a matter of
not listening to other points of view
other points of view can be said in
non-annoying ways right in
non-confrontational non-insulting ways
but if the way you're going to say
things is just
dumb or annoying or intentionally
trying to start an argument etc without
giving good rational reasons i'm not
learning from that i'm just being
annoyed by it and you're gone
harder to do with relatives and people
who we care about etc but ultimately i
think that people don't do that enough
either
okay varun nora
simhachar sorry for
getting your name mixed up a little bit
arun nara semacharm says
what is your attitude toward the
traditional values of honor and valor
and their role in defining the
conventional idea of masculinity
the challenges faced by humanity today
call for solutions that involve
inclusivity cooperation and nuanced
dialogue across tribalistic boundaries
as we were just saying by the way
which to a first approximation conflict
with the honor value value system i've
seen many people especially men lament
at the emasculation of culture in this
way
in my mind they are just clinging to a
value system that had had relevance in
traditional human societies but doesn't
anymore
i also think that the sentiment mostly
comes from male insecurity do you agree
or do you think that we must take such
concerns seriously and incorporate those
traditional values more into
contemporary human life
i would say i kind of
largely agree what i certainly agree
with is that
our
existence as human beings is in a very
different context now than it was
just a few hundred years ago much less
thousands of years ago right our
environment which we live in is a very
different place and that might very well
call for different values and different
organizations of society you know and
treating women and people of other uh
races and ethnicities and sexualities
and abilities
in a different way in a more inclusive
positive way is something we can do now
uh much more effectively if we choose to
do so than we might have been able to do
in the past with you know different
constraints and scarcity and economic
deprivation and things like that that we
had to deal with in the past i'm not
excusing bad behavior in the past but
simply at the level of explaining it you
can see why certain inequities and
certain hierarchies evolved in the past
that now we don't need anymore
right that now we just uh don't have the
same motivations or same justifications
or same uh original reasons for them to
exist anymore okay so in principle i'm
open to the idea that our set of values
whatever they are
might need to be updated from now to
from what it was a thousand years ago
and in particular uh notions of
masculinity and femininity are are
obvious examples right i mean the
traditional roles of men and women
are
what i should say is the current roles
that men and women have in the world are
very far away from what they
traditionally were right whether it's
giving birth and raising children or
having jobs or any of those things so a
complete rethink wouldn't be out of
place
having said that
i think that when you just say honor and
valor when you separate that from issues
of femininity and masculinity and just
ask about those questions
those are i think perfectly good values
honor is a good value valor is a good
value i mean maybe the
natural or at least commonplace
conflation of those values with
masculinity is misplaced but you know i
think that something called honor is a
good thing you know again any value can
go too far
you can take honor
too strongly or you can misconstrue it
or you could implement it in a
counterproductive way but the idea that
um i try to be an honorable person
i try to uh keep my promises i try to
fulfill my responsibilities um i try to
do a good job and not let people down
and other things that are
typically associated with the idea of
honor or even valor you could make a
similar
list about valor yeah these are
generally good things i think that's
usually good i think that if you listed
traditional
positively associated values sorry
positively associated values that are
traditionally associated with either men
or women they're usually all good right
you know being nurturing being loving
being communicative whatever the
traditional female values are those are
also
good
and maybe those are not i mean i think
the real issue is that
um
because we're in flux
right because society is changing in
ways that you know it's a pretty rapid
change in how we live our lives compared
to previous years previous generations
previous eras
people are left behind a little bit or
you know people still taught old ways of
thinking or valuing even though the
world is changing around them and that
leads to a lot of
mismatches between what people think
they've been taught about what they're
supposed to do and how they're supposed
to live and the world they find
themselves in and i'm actually pretty
sympathetic to people who are struggling
with that mismatch like i might think
that a certain person is acting badly
but if they're acting correctly
according to a certain value system then
i i'm not going to say they're acting
correctly by my value system but i'm
sympathetic to the fact that they're
trying their best according to their
value system and what we should do is
talk about it we shouldn't just judge
them badly and condemn them
we can condemn them but we can it's
better to try to reason with them try to
explain why
a more traditional understanding is not
appropriate in this particular
example um you know and this is all
mixed up with other
problems other issues that are kind of
not the same issue but they become
involved with it for other reasons right
like a lot of people who will
try to defend and advocate for a more
traditionalist view of honor and value
valor and masculinity have other agendas
and are using these words to
uh you know get
get sort of positively val balanced
vocabulary associated with whatever
their real
goals are so i'm not going to go into
too many details about that because i'm
sure it's very different in different
circumstances but something to keep in
mind that if a particular person you
disagree with is using this word it
might be the person's fault not the
word's fault
amanda bradford says has being born and
raised in the philadelphia area
influenced your personality
um yeah probably not too much uh so i
mean two answers to that question my
first instinct is to say no probably not
too much
in part because i grew up in the suburbs
of philadelphia i can't even claim to be
really you know inner city philadelphian
um
and also
yeah i mean partly because i think that
people overrate
the extent to which different
cities or different locations within one
country are really different from each
other like you know boston and
philadelphia will tell you stories about
how different they are and they're not
that different really
on the other hand if i'm a little bit
more honest and uh
self-aware
um everyone tends to think of wherever
they grew up as just normal
you know it's like everyone else is
judged in comparison to me it was
slightly hilarious for me to watch
um kate winslet in uh
uh uh what was the tv show you know the
tv show i'm talking about that was set
in the philadelphia suburbs um
mayor of east town yes mayor of east
town because that wasn't quite my accent
that they were speaking but i certainly
had friends who thought talked in that
accent it was a nearby accent the east
town uh
that's sort of just west of philadelphia
kind of accent i was north of
philadelphia but um
people don't think they talk with an
accent no one thinks they talk with an
accent unless other people explain to
them they just think they talk normally
everyone else talks weird right
and so
when i say that i don't you know i don't
think of myself as being strongly
affected by the fact that i grew up in
philadelphia that's
completely unfair to the extent that i'm
just thinking of suburban philadelphia
is just normal and everyone else is
weird right that's not true you know my
notion of what is normal is very much um
colored by growing up in the suburbs of
philadelphia going to a large public
school etc etc
sid huff says in a talk he gave in
advance of the cop26 meeting brian cox
argued that while there are plenty of
planets elsewhere in our galaxy which
could potentially support life many
fewer will have seen life emerge and
such life is very likely to be slime at
best
in other words not conscious sentient
life
he then suggested that planet earth may
be the only place in the galaxy
supporting sentient life and he
concluded that if life on earth were
destroyed eg by climate change that
would eliminate meaning in our galaxy
forever what do you make of all this
especially the part about eliminating
meaning
well you know i think that that scenario
he catches out is one that we should
have on the table and take seriously
i wouldn't necessarily attach to it a
high degree of credence for a few
reasons um
well sorry there's different parts of it
i think the least likely part of that
scenario is the idea that climate change
or some similar
catastrophe could literally destroy all
life on earth
i don't think that's the kind of thing
that would happen under climate change
it might enormously impact the quality
of our life and i don't want to downplay
how bad climate change would be but a
literal you know universal extinction
level event doesn't seem to me to be the
kind of thing that is likely because of
climate change
so i think that part of a statement like
that is motivated by putting the fear of
god into people right which is a
perfectly legitimate motivation we're if
anything extremely under-motivated to
combat climate change and so
making it sound scary is a natural
impulse to give into um but the other
part of the argument that uh life
elsewhere uh might be ubiquitous but
might not be highly technological and uh
or even highly conscious and intelligent
and complicated that's uh harder to
judge it's completely possible
in fact it's it's in some sense
obviously the simplest explanation for
the fermi paradox right why haven't we
found
intelligent life elsewhere in the
universe well because it's not there
because intelligent life is super duper
rare that could be either because life
is rare or intelligence is rare among
life etc so
something like that is completely
plausible to me
the final part
that
by eliminating intelligent life on earth
we will be eliminating meaning in our
galaxy or in the universe you know i get
it i i hear what is being said um
i'm not quite sure
what to make of that i mean i'm
sympathetic in general but i don't have
a
really clear intellectual argument it
goes back to what we were saying about
long-termism and extinction level
possibilities etc
um
you know i am certainly in favor of
making sure that thinking experiencing
meaningful life living creatures exist
and last for a very long time i i think
that one of the minimal values that it
is possible for a human being to have
and i haven't okay but if i'm honest and
someone says well why
it's hard to be precise about that and
like i said i could
very easily
see an argument that a little bit of
meaningful happy life is better than a
lot of miserable life even if there's
meaning in it right so that's not to
come down on one side of that or the
other it's just to say it's a reasonable
question
it's not obvious what the answer is
there so anyway let's not destroy life
on earth or even make it miserable
through climate change how about that
paul hess says i read that the powerful
gravitational waves resulting from black
hole mergers cause a reduction in mass
if this mass comes from inside the black
holes would you expect the expelled
energy contains information
or would it be another form of the
information paradox so it does not come
from inside the black holes um this is
hawking's area theorem so stephen
hawking proved that not only if you have
one black hole and do things to it the
area of the event horizon always
increases
but also if you have two black holes and
combine them the total area of the new
one black hole is always bigger than
greater than or equal to the area of the
two previous black holes combined and
the information inside is proportional
to the area of the event horizon that's
the famous formula from hawking and
beckenstein that entropy of the black
hole is the area of its event horizon uh
divided by four times newton's constant
so
information is not getting out whatever
information is inside those black holes
is still in there where the information
comes from it's from the energy
elsewhere like there's energy in the
fact that one black hole is orbiting
around the other one right that has
energy in it if if you had two black
holes and just really slowly moved them
into each other
no energy would be released but also no
gravitational waves either if you
dropped two black holes into each other
they would speed up as they came in
together right and there would be
gravitational waves but that's where the
energy that's where the gravitational
wave energy comes from it comes from the
motion of the black holes not from
inside them
brendan says sports question
what is your perspective on goat
greatest of all time discussions in the
realm of sports such as basketball
my perspective is it's fun but pretty
meaningless
i i'm definitely uh of two i think there
are two important facts you have to keep
in mind one is that
uh you can't compare people across eras
right i mean this is something that has
been said many many times but it still
remains true and people are going to do
it anyway
you just cannot compare shaquille o'neal
to will chamberlain
they live in different eras they were
trained in different ways they played
different games there was no three-point
line will chamberlain played etc etc the
league was much smaller when chamberlain
played uh it's a you know it's just an
impossible kind of comparison you can't
even compare michael jordan to uh wilt
chamberlain um
by any sort of traditional
impact on the game metrics will
chamberlain was definitely the goat um
but
maybe he didn't win as many rings as
other people did so you know there's
different criteria you can use and you
can pick and choose which criteria you
want to care about most and get
completely different answers which
should be a reminder that there's no
unique way to do this
the other point to keep in mind is
i do think that the end of the day even
though this is
obvious and trivial it's worth saying
if what you're talking about is sports
what matters is who wins the game that's
what matters right i mean that's what
matters to happiness or whatever and so
the perspective i have on this comes
from having been a
first-year student at villanova
that when they won the national
basketball championship the ncaa uh
college basketball championship and they
played in a famous game against
georgetown in the finals and for those
of you who were not there or you know
were too young or whatever or don't care
about basketball
at the time that year 1985
um
georgetown was this absolutely
overwhelmingly dominant basketball team
they had won the championship the year
before patrick ewing was the center and
he was considered the best uh college
basketball player and villanova was
nobody i mean they were ranked like
number 20th in the country or something
like that they had a sort of cinderella
run to the championship they had lost to
georgetown earlier in the year no one
gave them a chance and then villanova in
the game they played out of their minds
they made every shot they took and they
won by two points so you know in
consensus one of the biggest upsets and
most fun
final games in the history of the ncaa
basketball tournament
too bad you weren't there that's all i
can say it was a good time to be a
villanova basketball student but uh what
made me think of it is uh
the center for villanova at the time was
named ed pickney
pretty decent basketball player you know
he went on to play in the pros for a few
years
and uh patrick ewing of course went on
to be get have a hall of fame career in
the nba and they actually became friends
so they were
rivals in college but they became
friends and patrick ewing at one point
said yeah i convinced ed that uh really
our team was the better one
even though they won the game
and you know i think that
ed pickney gave up on that argument too
quickly like what does that mean
greatest better
who cares that's like a completely uh
hypothetical thing what matters is who
won the game that's what matters
and the point is that wilt chamberlain
will never play a game against shaquille
o'neal there's no win or loss record um
bill russell might not have been as
talented a basketball player as will
chamberlain was but his team won more
championships and you know wilt did win
a couple times the nba championship and
that counts
and russell won more and you know but
who cares like it's it's not even an
accumulation it's like who won that year
right
there's a famous quote um
if this was the greatest
what whatever whoops i'm gonna forget
exactly the quote you know if this was
the most important game how come they're
playing again next year every year
they'll be a new champion so i think
that's what matters who won that year
who won the championship who won the
game that you're watching i would enjoy
that rather than
playing these intellectual games about
who is better of all time that's my
perspective that's kind of a downer
perspective sorry about that still fun
to argue about
p walder says in the recent clubhouse
discussion with philip gough
you explained that adoption of a pansys
view of reality would require a complete
reworking of our best understanding of
the laws of physics goff required by
saying that his version of panpsychism
did not postulate any new properties as
he was suggesting that the charge and
spin properties of particles was
consciousness this part of the
discussion wasn't continued so could you
explain why this encounter of penn
psychism fails so
yeah i did not claim that i know that
philip claimed i claimed that but that's
not what i claimed what i said i do
really try to be clear about this but
somehow
what i say does not get communicated in
other people's brains very effectively
so i'm going to try again
i'm not saying that pansychism entails
that you change the laws of physics what
i'm saying is that if you want to be
pancyst you have a choice
there's a dilemma
and there are two horns of the dilemma
and you're on one of them okay
one of the horns of the dilemma is you
change the known laws of physics you
alter with the core theory you imagine
that some other element
of reality is somehow affecting the
motions of particles to push them away
from what they would do according to the
known laws of physics okay that is one
possibility
but there's another possibility which is
that you invent something penn psychist
some version of reality in which
consciousness plays a fundamental role
without
changing any of the behavior predicted
by the laws of physics that's the other
whole horn of the dilemma
so you cannot wriggle out of the dilemma
by saying well i take the other horn
because the problem with the other horn
is
the zombie problem you know like i said
uh i think i said this in in the
discussion by the way i'm having uh i'm
appearing on phillips podcast philip
goff has a podcast philip was of course
a guest on minescape um where i tried it
as usual to let him have most of the uh
talking
but he has a podcast with keith frankish
and and philip is pro pansys and keith
is a philosopher who is anti-panzerkist
so i'm going to appear on their podcast
and that should be available soon
but anyway
the original version of the paper that i
wrote to which philip was responding was
called the zombie argument for
physicalism
and it entirely focused on this horn of
the dilemma the horn where you say i
don't change the laws of physics but i i
rewrote it because i realized other
people have already said it and they
said it better than me in particular
katie balog who is a philosopher at
rutgers
[Music]
rutgers newark i think but she's written
very very good papers explaining this
point of view and the point of view is
the following look
the zombie argument says
imagine a world which i claim is
conceivable where
it's exactly exactly exactly the same
physical behavior as our world but
there's no consciousness right so there
can be people called zombies that live
in this world that act exactly as we do
but they don't have really conscious
experiences okay
and the zombie argument as formulated by
david chalmers another previous
mindscape guest says
if that's possible
if it's possible to conceive of
a ring possible worlds not our world but
a different possible world where all the
behavior is exactly the same but
consciousness is absent
then consciousness can't be physical
because i have two worlds both of which
are physically exactly the same but one
of which has consciousness and one of
which doesn't okay
so here's my response to that um
let's say that you
well the short response is to deny the
premise that zombies are conceivable
that you know you think you can conceive
of zombies but i claim you really can't
and here's a reason why the longer
reason
what you're imagining is a person who
acts exactly like me but doesn't have
that inner conscious experience okay but
i think that they're not really taking
seriously enough the idea of exactly the
same as me behaving in exactly the same
way okay because what that means is that
a zombie
would say they were conscious
a zombie if david if there was a zombie
david chalmers that zombie david
chalmers would invent the zombie
argument in favor of
non-physicalism of consciousness if
there were a zombie philip goff zombie
philip goff would write a book in favor
of panpsychism because that's a behavior
if someone says i am experiencing the
redness of red or i am in love or i am
sad that statement they are making
is a behavior
so what that means is if you can
conceive of zombies
the zombies are reporting what they take
to be their innermost experiences right
i mean the zombies aren't lying to you
any more than a regular person is lying
to you when a zombie says i am
experiencing the redness of red they
think they're experiencing the redness
of red
why would it be anything else that's the
natural
meaning given to the word thinking
so
the point is that
your evidence
for the non-physical nature of
consciousness
came from your own personal
introspection from the fact that you
experience
something that you don't think can be
explained by the purely physical
behavior of matter but the zombie
thought experiment provides excellent
evidence that if zombies are conceivable
then introspection is entirely
unreliable
because the zombies are reporting their
results of introspection also and
they're completely wrong because they're
saying that they're conscious and
they're not
so what this really gets down to is the
fact that
the kind of consciousness that is
purportedly being explained
by pansychism if you don't change the
laws of physics is the kind of
consciousness that has no effect on
behavior
a kind of consciousness that is
completely unrelated to what we talk
about when we talk about consciousness
because our talking is a behavior
our talking obeys the laws of physics
right and if that's what you're
explaining if you're explaining
something that literally cannot be
reported on talked about or have any
influence on how we behave then i don't
think you're explaining consciousness at
all
what kind of conscience is it that has
no effect on my behavior at all that's
not what i think of when i think of
consciousness anyway
that's what i meant
by that horn of the dilemma but i
downgraded it in the paper i wrote
because
bolog and others have talked about it
better than i did you can read the paper
consciousness and the laws of physics is
my paper and i cite these other people
who talk about it if you want more
details and a more a more nuanced
philosophical argument than i just gave
you
casey says i'm curious about the state
of cosmic inflation in 2021 it seems
like 10 or 15 years ago it was the thing
but i haven't heard it come up much
recently is it still a leading idea for
explaining the early rapid expansion of
the universe where do you stand on it
these days uh yeah i don't think its
status has changed that much um
which doesn't mean it's wrong by the way
like a lot of people
have implicitly or explicitly this idea
that if an idea has been around a long
time and it's not been proven right or
wrong it must be wrong because it hasn't
been proven right or wrong that's not
how ideas work right uh this is a
feature of modern physics like it or not
that we just have to learn to deal with
which is that
our theories that we have and have
experimentally tested
work they fit the data so by
construction the theories that we have
that have not yet been tested like
inflation
like supersymmetry or whatever um
they're just not being tested by the
data and so we just don't know and it's
really really really hard to test them
and it might take a long time it might
even not happen it might very well not
happen a lot of lifetimes let's put it
that way anyway
um
there was a brief moment
several years ago when we thought that
the bicep2
telescope might have seen evidence for
inflation people got very excited about
that it turned out to be wrong it turned
out to be a misanalysis of the data more
recently the bicep 3 experiment came
along and
they actually put even tighter
constraints on inflation than we had
before but there's still plenty of room
for inflation to be there so i would say
that inflation in 2021 is still the
leading idea that we have about the
early universe and in most particularly
about the origin of structure the origin
of the fluctuations that grow into
galaxies etc but we have no more direct
evidence for it than we had in 1998
or something like that i say 1998
because that's when we found
that the dark energy the acceleration of
the universe that made the universe flat
as inflation predicted that was the last
major thing there's a tiny bit of
evidence for inflation that has
subsequently come up because
you know we talked before about
scale-free phenomena things that more or
less the same size on every scale well
the perturbations uh in cosmology are an
example
the perturbations we see in cosmology
are roughly speaking scale-free they're
about the same amplitude at every length
scale and that's a very simple natural
thing in some ways so if you didn't know
where something came from but it was
scale-free you might
feel like you were in trouble because
there's too many ways to explain it okay
but inflation came along uh and it
wasn't even trying to explain scale-free
perturbations it was realized a couple
years after
it came along that it did predict
scale-free perturbations but even better
than that
inflation predicted that the
perturbations would be not quite
scale-free okay predicted the
perturbations be if i'm getting the sign
right a little bit larger on small
scales than on larger scales
and uh no i think i got that wrong a
little bit larger on larger scales than
on smaller scales the inflaton is
rolling down its potential so the
perturbations are getting smaller
at later times and therefore smaller
scales
so what inflation actually predicts is
almost but not quite
scale-free perturbations and that is
exactly what we observe we observe
perturbations that are almost scale-free
but not quite they're tilted a little
bit exactly as inflation would naturally
predict
that's weak evidence but it's still
evidence it should increase your
credence in inflation just a little bit
i think that inflation has real
conceptual issues
that it has to deal with why did
inflation start in the first place
roughly speaking why did was there a
sufficiently low entropy starting point
that inflation got off the ground but
the fact that it has an issue to deal
with doesn't mean it can't deal with it
i just think that that's something where
inflationary cosmologists should be very
very worried about this and it's
annoying to me that they're not but okay
maybe they will get there someday
pair magnuson says in the episode with
nigel goldenfeld you talk about the
scale-free behavior of many different
systems there you go
is there a connection between the scale
freeness and vastly different systems
and the one over f noise we also observe
an impressive number of seemingly
completely unrelated systems um short
answer is i don't know i'm answering
this question not because i have any
wisdom to impart whatsoever uh but i
think it's a good connection to draw
just so people know about it i mean
there's this idea of one over f noise
one over frequency so that's a power law
right and power laws are associated with
scale-free behavior
um
so maybe there is some connection but i
think one over f noise is sufficiently
common and like you say in so many
unrelated systems i don't necessarily
want to connect it to the same kind of
origins of scale-free behavior
that nigel was talking about because
that was very specifically in the
context of critical phenomena where
there was some phase transition where
you're poised at the point of the phase
transition i don't want to attribute
that explanation necessarily uh to this
completely universal phenomenon but
maybe it's there i don't know
tom says in your interview with stephen
wolfram you ask him there's an
understanding in traditional quantum
computing that there are some problems
for which quantum mechanics certainly
gives you a speed up are you saying
that's not true in your model
and he replies yeah i think it's not
going to be true that's my guess
i've seen other people say that they
don't think quantum computing will work
from a theoretical standpoint even
recently
have those working on it practically not
shown it to work yet is it still
possible quantum computing doesn't work
at all um
it's certainly not possible the quantum
computing doesn't work at all because it
works it's been done okay uh in fact you
can go visit uh i think we mentioned
this in the podcast with john preschool
you can meant you can visit the ibm
quantum experience at least i think it
was there that was a website that used
to exist where you can run uh an
algorithm on a quantum computer with a
small number of qubits go ahead and do
it and it will give you the answer
whatever probabilistic answer appears
from your algorithm
that is not a demonstration that you
have sped up versus some classical
algorithm in fact it's the other way
around the actual
you know six qubits or whatever they
have work more slowly than a classical
simulation of it and it's much faster to
run the classical simulation of it but
as you scale up you might very well hit
places where quantum algorithms are
faster
personally i think it's extremely
unlikely that there is some modification
of quantum mechanics that prevents
quantum computers from working i don't
even know what that would look like um
so i don't know so if stephen wolfram
wants to predict it
that's the kind of prediction i would
encourage people like him to make way
more precise
because you can be that i mean that
would be the gold standard like that's a
prediction you could make that is
testable and would show that you're
writing quantum mechanics is wrong and
nobel prizes would rain down on your
head if you did that so that's what i
would be working on if i if i actually
thought that was a plausible thing
regular
says i need to hear your stance on the
anthropic principle
technically not a question but that's
okay we'll give it a shot um you know
there's a obviously uh
there's different levels of anthropic
principle there's sort of crazy levels
where you say the world exists so that
we can be here i give approximately zero
credence to that version of the
anthropic principle there is a super
obviously true version of the anthropic
principle that says given the universe
in which we live there's a selection
effect that says that we human beings
are going to find ourselves in the parts
of the universe where we can possibly
exist
right i mean
we here we are in the solar system on
the surface of the earth
we do not live on the surface of the sun
as isn't that weird there's a lot more
surface area on the sun there's a lot
more cubic volume in empty space than
here on the surface of the earth is this
a weird bizarre inexplicable thing
no it is not why because of the
anthropic principle because there's a
selection effect because intelligent
living creatures are more likely to be
found in hospitable environments than
inhospitable ones that's a completely
trivial inarguable version of the
anthropic principle
the there's an in-between version which
is again
trivially true
if the conditions are met which is that
if there are regions of the universe
where physical conditions are wildly
different
so not just the difference between the
sun and the earth but different laws of
physics right different you know mass of
the electron or whatever
if those different regions exist then
again there could be a selection effect
it may be that in certain regions living
intelligent creatures are more likely to
arise than in other ones and again you
would predict on the basis of very
trivial reasoning that we're going to
find ourselves in the regime where we
can be existing okay now
that's not trivial even though it's the
reasoning is trivial the uh result is
not because it tells you something about
the explanatory
power of your theories of the universe
the classic example is the cosmological
constant the vacuum energy okay
here are two different
attitudes one can have towards the
cosmological constant what attitude is
well there's a multiverse
the values of the cosmological constant
are different from place to place in the
multiverse if it's very large either
very large and positive or very large
and negative then either there's no then
there's basically speaking no time
for intelligent beings to exist
therefore there's an anthropic selection
effect and intelligent beings will find
themselves in regions where the
cosmological constant is small lo and
behold we find ourselves in a region
where the cosmos constant is small okay
that's it that's an attitude another
attitude is um
there exists a predictive theory that
explains why the cosmological constant
is small once and for all okay there is
a unique value you can have it is
predictable in terms of other constants
of nature and it's the only value it
could have had and we don't yet know
what that theory is right that's another
attitude you could have so the point is
the anthropic principle you know the
reasoning in the first example is 100
valid
makes sense but we don't know whether
the whether the antecedent is true we
don't know if there is a multiverse out
there so even though the reasoning is
solid we don't know if it's the correct
reasoning for our universe
but it could be
if we somehow knew that it was
we would stop looking for this
predictive theory right if we knew there
were different values of the cosmos
constant in different regions of space
you would not spend your valuable
research time looking for a theory that
predicted a unique value because you
knew it couldn't be right
so that's why this uh so i'm not saying
which is right and which is wrong right
now since we don't know it's worth
exploring both
alternatives but it's certainly not
worth saying
you can't
take seriously the idea there's a
multiverse and invoke the anthropic
principle because we can't see the other
universes so therefore it's not science
that's a completely bizarre point of
view to have even if we can't see the
other universes whether or not that
scenario is true is a perfectly physical
sensible question about the universe and
it's a question that affects the way
that we think about the universe that
affects the models that we do build so
we have to take that possibility into
consideration i don't think it's in any
sense subtle that it's the right way of
thinking about the cosmos constant but
it's absolutely on the table
okay i think we're down to just two last
questions uh dominic adam jones says
when applying bayesian reasoning to
questions like whether it rained last
night all seemed to work fine however
when applying it to scientific theories
it seems more problematic given we can
be pretty sure none of our current
theories is 100 correct
it seems that we should apply low
credences to all current theories but
that doesn't seem to correspond to how
we behave nor how we feel
so this is an excellent question but i
think there is a resolution i think
there is an answer this is one of those
times when i say it's an excellent
question because i know the answer
sure
none of our current theories is 100
correct but
a good theory won't be 100 wrong either
uh you know sometimes theories are 100
wrong you know if you go back to the
19th century there were theories of the
phlogiston theory of combustion or
something like that or the plum pudding
model of the atom which were just wrong
right to the geocentric model of the
solar system um but a good theory a
better theory will be
somewhat correct we'll capture some true
behavior of the universe newtonian
mechanics or newtonian gravity
is
does capture something true about the
universe it could be rigorously derived
as a limit of general relativity or
special relativity or quantum mechanics
right
so
the interesting thing is that when you
go from
i mean
classical to quantum is the best example
but even when you go from newtonian
space-time to relativistic space-time
your ontology changes right your
fundamental way that you describe
reality changes
but as we talked about with james
ladyman the philosopher a long time ago
there's something that is preserved even
in those transitions some structural
thing some relationship between
different parts of the theory so when we
say things like you know the standard
model of particle physics is correct
it's not as you say 100 correct it will
give out it will have some domain of
applicability
but it will never entirely go away
when i say that the table in front of me
is made of atoms and the atoms have in
them electrons protons and neutrons that
will never stop being true even if we
learn that electrons and protons and
neutrons are made of other things and
that space time is made of other things
and it's all just a wave function or all
just bits or something like that
there will always be
a level of description on which it is
correct to say the table is made of
atoms and those atoms are made of
electrons protons and neutrons so i
think that's a perfectly legitimate
attitude to have towards scientific
theories the good ones capture something
true that is never going to go away
final question is from kyle stevens who
says in your recent episode with david
wallace david states on the topic of
boltzmann brains and the infinite if the
universe is such that it predicts that
it's full of beings who have fake
histories there is some reason to worry
that the theory is self-undermining
do you hold this same concern should we
assign some queens to the possibility
that we ourselves are simply boltzmann
brains uh so yes i do hold the same
concern in fact this concern was largely
my fault uh it was articulated by me in
a paper called why boltzmann brains are
bad and so i'm letting david talk but
he's basically quoting me i'm sure that
other people had rough ideas that were
similar i don't want to claim too much
originality there but i think that i did
put it
in very clear definitive words
for one of the first people to do that
if not the first person to do that
uh and the basic idea is you know even
so the traditional way that physicists
think about the boltzmann brain problem
if they think it's a problem is that
they say
if you have a cosmological model that
predicts that most people like us are
boltzmann brains then i should be a
boltzmann brain and i'm not therefore
the theory is ruled out by data okay so
i think that's entirely bogus that
reasoning and i've had arguments with
people about this but as i said before
when we were talking about me versus sir
isaac newton there's zero
credence that secretly i should have
been or could have been or would have
been isaac newton i'm me isaac newton is
isaac newton i'm not a boltzmann brain
so in
i'm i'm me let's put it that way
whatever i am whether i'm not a
boltzmann brain i am not a brain
floating out in uh empty space
because that would have very different
experiences than i'm having um
even if
most of the intelligent beings in the
universe were brains floating out in
empty space i am clearly not one of them
okay
that does not rule out the theory
because in that theory there's also a
lot of people who are not brains
floating out in empty space and the
relative numbers don't matter i'm
someone who believes that when you do
these anthropic reasonings you're
allowed to take into account the data
you have
the data i have already tells me i'm not
a boltzmann brain so i can't be
re-surprised
by that fact when i look around and i
notice it okay so that's not the
evidence against the universe dominated
by boltzmann brains the evidence against
that kind of universe is that even when
i take into account all of the data i
have even when i say oh look here i'm in
a room and there are tables i feel a
gravitational field under my feet
there's clearly a big earth-like thing
beneath me i believe that outside
there's something called the city of
boston etc
even when i conditionalize on all that
in a universe that is dominated by
random fluctuations
zero of my beliefs about the outside
world are likely to be true
even though i believe i'm in a state
called massachusetts
there's almost no chance that that's
actually correct right it is far more
likely that my belief in the state of
massachusetts randomly fluctuated into
my brain
than that the entire state of
massachusetts randomly fluctuated into
existence okay
so
and that's what david wallace is
referring to the real problem with the
boltzmann brain scenario is not that
it's ruled out by data
but that it leads you to conclude that
all your beliefs about the world are
wrong
including the ones that led you to
believe that there's a boltzmann brain
problem so you cannot simultaneously
believe that this the universe with
random fluctuations is true and that you
have good reasons to believe that it is
true that's what it means to be
self-undermining
so my solution to that is to just
give very very low credence to
cosmological scenarios with all these
random fluctuations in them in other
words the conclusion i reach is roughly
speaking exactly the same as someone who
says well boltzmann brain's just ruled
out by the data namely that if your
cosmological scenario features
domination by random fluctuations then
you should throw it out you should try
to do better build a better cosmological
scenario but my reasoning for getting
there is different um
and there i i
i wanted to talk about this question
because there is like one little
lingering thread
that uh can be pulled on here which is
not completely
settled in my mind which is that
i don't want to give zero
credence to the idea that i'm a
boltzmann brain because i don't want to
give zero credence to any logically
consistent possibility and the reason is
because if you give zero credence to
something then literally no future
information can make you believe it
right you're multiplying zero by some
finite number you're still going to get
zero in bayes's formula
so you always need to be open to the
possibility that new information will
come in that will change your mind so
every possibility should have some
non-zero credence but it should be very
very small and so we get back into this
question of what do we do with really
really really unlikely things in the
universe whether it's branches of the
wave function existential risks or what
have you i'm not sure we have a really
well developed uh theory for dealing
with these kinds of things so my current
attitude is just say no to boltzmann
brain cosmologies and if evidence comes
in that it's a better fit than what i
think then i'll change i'll update
accordingly but it won't be a formal
bayesian updating it'll be you know a
fuzziness becoming a little bit clearer
that's something we can all aim for
fuzziness becoming a little bit clearer
something to aspire for to toward uh
so happy halloween everybody it's
halloween 2021 uh november is coming
talk to you soon thanks for your support
for the mindscape podcast
keep listening tell your friends bye
[Music]
you